good morning everybody
um
for those of you who are signing in on
different bills or pink cards we'd ask
you to do it quietly please we're going
to get going on
the hearing
okay before we start uh
representative stavis would you like to
lead us in the pledge please before we
get going today
okay good morning everybody we're going
to open up the hearing on House Bill 95.
and we will call I see the prime sponsor
here representative Reed
thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members of the municipal and
County committee for hearing my
testimony today
um hb95 would enable municipalities to
enact regulations regarding rental
practices
I will because we all know that we are
in a major major housing crisis though
some of us particularly say in my region
the Seacoast may be more intimately
familiar with the problem I'll speak a
little bit to that but I'll try not to
belabor the point
we are increasingly in a housing crisis
it's been going on for a long time but
has gotten much worse in recent years
and very frequent when we talk about
housing crises in general we think about
them I think at this level as Workforce
housing crises in in terms of well how
can people work in these towns if they
cannot afford to live in or even near
these downs
and that is certainly true and important
and it's also just housing like it's
literally about people having shelter
over their head so I want to kind of
hold both as we continue forward
um connected is the crisis that I've
heard so many times in my six years here
which is the graying of New Hampshire
the idea that we can neither keep nor
attract younger people to the state
in my six years I've heard a number of
propositions to try to ameliorate that
including things like building water
parks I want to quote an old political
quote when people said it's the it's the
economy stupid I want to say it's the
housing stupid it's the housing people
cannot come here not so representative
Reed could you hold on one second I
forgot to do a very important thing at
the beginning of our meeting
Mr clerk could you call the roll oops
surely Mr chairman uh Vice chairman
power
here
represent Guthrie
collects here
representative Rosales
I'm here
uh representative
thank you
representative Kelly
representative award here
representative Brown
representative Cahill
here
represents Davis here
representative Tetro
representative tree eleven
representative Gilman here
representative majority
okay representative Mega putty
representative Gallagher
representative Hicks here
representative Holland
here
representative priests here
and the chairman
present thank you thank you Mr clerk I
apologize representative Reed continue
thank you Mr chair just as I was getting
on a roll no I'm just kidding
um the to restate what I just said the
point is is that we cannot attract or
keep young people here not because New
Hampshire isn't desirable it most
certainly is attractive in almost every
conceivable way it is because they have
nowhere to live here they cannot buy a
home they can't even rent a place in a
lot of the places that they would be
able to work in so we are really talking
about two crises at the same time
um and there's a reason it's called a
crisis it's an emergency and certainly
in my area the Seacoast it is truly an
emergency people are getting pushed out
of their homes but not just their homes
they're getting pushed out of entire
towns entire regions and once you're
pushed out of a region you're pushed out
of your job for most people that I'm
talking about and in fact many people in
my area are being pushed out of this
State entirely
and a lot of what we've been seeing we
attribute to the market
I'll just give the example of what has
happened in my town over the last couple
years but coming to a head this past
summer one particular
person that comes from a developer
Financial family started buying up
multiple in fact I think the majority of
our multi-family housing properties
downtown
in many cases paying in our current
market as of this summer paying 50
percent more than the market rate which
apparently is the actual Trend and I'll
get to that in a second with the
explicit purpose of raising rents and
this particular person was Raising rents
two and a half times in some cases what
people were paying these people were our
local post office workers the people who
worked in our local restaurants that
were very proud of in New Market
a lot of young professionals but also
veterans retired veterans one of whom
had lost his wife another battling stage
three cancer so all in all by my count
this particular landlord in his
practices pushed out over a hundred
residents of my town of Newmarket within
a year
most of were forced to leave the town
many were forced to leave the state
all for and I have no problem with
people owning properties and renting it
out it's the predatory aspect of going
into it knowing that you're going to
displace people I mean you have a choice
of how you make money if you have
investment funds you can you know build
a sweater Factory I don't know you can
do anything but to specifically go into
the business of displacing people out of
their homes for profit I I find to be
predatory and that's kind of where I
want to go with this
um so that was the story in New Market
but it's been happening everywhere in
fact there is one very public
proprietor I guess you'd call them I
kind of don't want to call them a
landlord because sometimes landlords
just own a couple of units but uh in in
Manchester who very publicly has posted
and coached and gloated on this exact
model then and saying very specifically
pay whatever you have to pay if it's a
hundred percent over market value pay
that there's essentially he said there's
no limit to what you can pay for a
property that would make it not
profitable you can raise the rent as
much as you want
that person was out of Manchester by the
way
now my town my town of Newmarket was
trying their best to deal with this
crisis that we were having because of
several landlords but primarily the one
I've spoken about but as you know towns
have very very little that they can do I
don't have to tell you about Dylan's
Rule and and the fact that we have to
enable towns to have any tools at their
disposal whatsoever
um
I just think that we do go out of our
way to protect property and protect
people with property we should also do
maybe as much to enable towns to protect
the people who don't have property
we need to remind ourselves that the
people that we're talking about are part
of our communities they are restaurant
workers bus drivers such as myself
and it frustrates me that when we
finally do get around to talking about
this problem it's often in the uh the
vein of their value as a worker and not
the basic right to have a roof over your
head because for them it's not a
cerebral issue about Jews does the
economy have enough workers it's about
am I going to be living in my car next
month
it's about what do I do with my cat if
I'm living in my car do I have to move
my kids into a different School
these are real issues that affect people
on a very intimate and real way and I
kind of like I said want to keep that as
we go on so to get to the bones of the
bill this bill is enabling only as I
said I don't have to explain why that is
to you or the mechanism of that
and allows municipalities to set
different kinds of regulations on the
rental market I suspect there will be
detractors that will cry rent control
and all you know all that comes along
with that and it could a town could
potentially decide to have an actual
rent control but this is also rent
stabilization I think primarily rent
stabilization it provides a number of
tools at the town's disposal it's also
just notification of rent hikes can a
town say you know maybe for now while
the market is so very hot and while
people are suffering maybe we have a
six-month notice period
so there's a number of different kind of
scalpel level tools that this would give
the town to address the issue and I need
to Mark here that it doesn't apply to
like those small landlords I was talking
about earlier maybe somebody with an Adu
on their property this replies only to
restricted properties so I believe the
definition of that and we have experts
better than myself is anything over four
units but
um
just to make that clear
now towns unlike states are very agile
if we were to try to propose something
like this it would be probably two years
before we could undo it
but towns can enact something and very
very quickly once they get that
Balancing Act of the market Forces
versus people being able to live they
can quickly
repeal it so giving them the tools to do
that
allows them to have that agile emergency
response but most importantly for the
most part this is going to be funny that
I say this it's not going to happen
towns are not going to do this and when
they do they'll only do it long enough
to address an actual emergency in crisis
and the reason I know that is because
the incentive for towns is to have
higher property values that's how they
get their revenue
so since towns want higher property
values it is against the town's interest
to actually regulate rents and keep them
low
however
Town governance and town people know
best what's in the best interest for
their towns and if this Balancing Act
has gone too far in One Direction where
people literally can't live and there
are no workers in that Community anymore
that can that can even live close to
that Community to work then that's an
emergency and that's a time where
the town should have the tools at their
disposal to try to reshift that
Balancing Act
foreign
and like I said
um they are they are intimately familiar
with their towns they know best both the
housing market and the whether or not
people are able to afford homes and
whether or not people are working so if
for example people in my town and I
think that if this was enabled I still
would have a very uphill climb
convincing My Town counselors to adopt
something like this but let's say that
our Our Town Council decided to adopt
something like this because they see the
emergency in that town who then are we
here in Concord to say Newmarket doesn't
know what's in new Market's best
interest even though Newmarket would
have the ability to quickly repeal that
who are we to tell them we from
disparate parts of the state that may
not look anything like Newmarket
and you know there's the whole concept
of local governance being Laboratories
of democracy we talk about believing in
local control Laboratories of democracy
so because they're so agile they can
quickly undo anything that once it you
know balances the wrong direction so
wouldn't that be educational for the
rest of us would that not then be aha
that is that is a regulation that goes
too far that will have this consequence
that information is extremely useful to
us for our own towns but also for
potential future State ideas of how to
deal with these crises
but in general
um I just want you to think of this as
like going to the ER with some severe
medical condition
when you have a severe medical condition
the doctor May give you things that are
otherwise you know risky or have side
effects like medicine or surgery or some
procedure that if you're healthy you
don't want and don't need
but you need it in an emergency and that
is what we are experiencing especially
on the Seacoast
um
I'm trying to wrap things up as quickly
as possible to give other people time to
speak
so I'll just I'll just close by saying
that I know that for a lot of us here up
in Concord this issue may be pretty
cerebral a lot of us have stable housing
a lot of us may have bought houses when
houses were five figures a lot of us may
own our homes outright so it may be more
of a intellectual exercise
but I do want to ask that you continue
to hold in your minds that this is a
very real issue that has very tangible
impacts on many many people especially
as not just knowing the national numbers
60 of our country is living paycheck to
paycheck
so this bill is enabling only
uh towns are in the best place to know
what is in the best interests of their
towns and have every reason not to enact
these things but need to have these
emergency tools at their disposal in
case they do and they're in the best
place to undo them when the time comes
to undo them
um
and with that I will take questions
thank you
thank you representative Reed do we have
any questions
representative yokella
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
I see that you
um chose to allow municipalities to do
these
um
via bylaws and bylaws only require a
public hearing and and even if the
entire public came and said we don't
like this this is not for our town the
governing body would be able to pass
that by law anyways and
um there would be no way for those
voters to say this is not other than you
know going through the process of
voting those people out there's no way
is there a question
so yes thank you would you believe um no
um
it's a statement that that that is the
case so why did you choose
um
um by law versus
um a vote of the actual uh legislative
body at the Town municipality level
thank you for the question and I do as a
general principle I teach American
government at Community College so I'm a
very big I'm a very big small D
democracy kind of person that believes
in self-governance at the uh the lowest
level possible
um so in general and I have another bill
in that is enabling that I just spoke to
yesterday unrelated to you all that um
that I did do as a vote of the
townspeople but as I repeatedly said in
my testimony this is an emergency
situation and the town governance has
every reason to not want to pass these
things anyway because it will in
eventually inversely impact the market
and therefore their revenue so because
they already have the incentive to not
want to do any of these and because is
they are held accountable within the
following year for Municipal elections
in their own position and because this
is an emergency
I feel that having the town governance
be able to do it without necessarily
waiting until the next Municipal are
there any other questions for
representative Reed representative Brown
I actually have just two short questions
I I don't understand the emergency
nature of this so maybe you could
explain that to me and then I'll have a
follow-up question
um I I'm not I guess I'm at a loss for
anything in addition to what I've
already explained there are people I
mean I counted I literally counted the
people being displaced out of my town
and when I say displaced it's not as if
they just oh they go next door and rent
another one and isn't that fine because
of the nature of what's happening and
specifically predatory practices they're
being priced out of entire regions and
in some cases the state I'm on the
Seacoast so people are going to Maine
they're going as far as I know like back
home to other states like Florida so we
are losing good people good workers if
you want to think of them that way but
it's it's not just this nebulous like
economic thing yes it is an economic
thing and yes it is about losing I mean
we've heard so much about not having
enough Workforce anyway so you can think
of it in those terms but I'm literally
thinking about it in the terms of the
over 100 people who were pushed out of
my town some of which had to leave the
entire region and their jobs some of
which had to stay in a car for a Time
some of which had to move back home with
their parents that's an emergency
so
did you have a follow-up representative
Brown
go ahead in in regard to uh the answer
you gave regarding the bylaws versus the
legislative body can you just clarify
that a little bit more for me why that
process is important to just have a the
bylaws versus allowing the legislative
body to vote on I know you mentioned
that about elections coming up but can
you clarify it again why why you think
that's important so I don't know if you
mean when you say legislative body if
you mean the electorate so the question
is
um who do you want making these
decisions and like we do with all levels
of government government you know some
things for example we allow
Administration to do because it's to
find detail and they need the agility to
act and enact different rules and
regulations things that don't need to be
put legislatively into statute but they
need to be able to do that it's a kind
of a similar thing in fact all
government is representational so when
we elect a town select board for example
example or in my case the Town Council
we are electing people to make those
kind of short quick decisions for us and
then we have the yearly not only
elections for those officers but also
elections for anything else we want to
put on the warrant so the reason I said
I opted to allow the governing body of
the town to make these decisions is
because they are more agile rather than
waiting in an emergency rather than
waiting a full year up to a full year to
put something on the warrant which I
don't know that we would even be able to
do that right now at this point you
still need to enable you still need to
enable the towns but they have the more
ability to both enact and repeal than
waiting for a yearly election and as
always our representatives are held
accountable and it's kind of fortunate
we have yearly elections for municipal
level thanks for your notification
foreign
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question do
you
um do you anticipate with the language
here that the governing body is free to
choose any source to
uh establish what the increase can be or
do you assume that there will be a
single source that the legislative body
would have to go to to say based on
X based on U.S Census Bureau based on
the BLS etc etc or do you do you
anticipate that they had the freedom uh
in my bill they have the freedom we do
not micromanage them and that is because
these Market forces are fast acting and
how could we possibly predict you know
for example the the housing market in
two months in Portsmouth for example but
Portsmouth City councilors have that
information and are better able to
respond so in terms of what would they
draw on we're not limiting any
information however in statute we do
have a Workforce housing formula that
they could easily go to and plug in
numbers and use that I'm not mandating
that but um but yeah that's that's
available to them
foreign
Gallagher
um
hi representative Reed um so just for
disclosure purposes I'm a co-sponsor on
this legislation and uh due to the new
rural um about either testifying or
asking questions uh I am taking the
asking questions
uh choice of that prong uh today
um so yeah I was wondering um
if you're familiar with the
um
academic usage of the phrase rent
seeking Behavior and the field of
economics and
um if so if you could talk about uh how
that relates to the um
more
General colloquial case
of rent that we're talking about here
I've definitely heard the the term and
I'm aware I believe that it is
um
it's not a good one right it's it's uh
it's I I might be stepping too far but
implies something that I might call
predatory but I admittedly can't you
know give you a wonderful academic
definition
okay
um
do you have a follow-up question on that
or a second question
or well not on that specifically I'll
pass thank you any other questions
representative power
thank you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question so
my my question is is that I understand
uh based on the language of this bill
that there will be a maximum amount and
owner of a restricted property can can
charge for rent my question is is what
then happens if the property is sold and
a new owner takes possession of the
property what how does the this bill
address that does the new owner inherit
that
um
rent limit fee limitation
thank you for the question so my
interpretation certainly the intent but
I believe the the bill is written well
uh and my interpretation of how it is
written is consistent with my intent
that towns would be able to enable
regulations on rental practices in
general and so that applies to whoever
the owner is so if a property is sold
then you know it's within a town then
it's not like you know it it goes with
that owner it's not that you're you know
specifically regulating John Doe who
owns things and when John Doe doesn't
own things you're not regulating
anything because John Doe doesn't own
things you're regulating the owner of
the unit that is renting it out
whoever the owner happens to be you're
regulating the rental practice which
inherently means a restriction on what
the owner is charging
or their practices
representative Davis
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Reed for taking my
question
um the bill doesn't State any amounts
which I assume to be intentional
so I'm wondering
I'm wondering what happens should this
bill pass and be signed into law
and a town or a city enacts bylaws
pursuant to this law
what are the guidelines
who knows who's who according to whom is
too much too much
so as I thank you for the question
um
as I said and I don't think it can be
overstated
the incentive on town government any
official of the town government is to
get Revenue
restricting rental amounts especially if
it's severe so just to be clear there's
a lot of different things that a town
can do that are not severe rent control
as we would call rent control there's
limiting rental increases to 15 percent
per year which is a kind of a mild rent
stabilization tactic there's changing
the notification period of rent
increases which doesn't affect the
amount at all but just says you know
maybe you need to give six months before
so there's all these different tools
available
um
but at the thrust of my argument has
consistently been we from being from
disparate parts of the state cannot know
what's in the best interest of any one
particular town the way that a town
government knows their own town the way
the town's people know their own town
and just to be very clear even though
this isn't the bylaws yes people would
show up and have their opinions heard
and certainly Town counselors Town
select board City councilors would uh
would understand that their townspeople
would happily vote them out if they
don't go along with what they want so I
still expect a fair amount a good
healthy robust amount in fact of um
townspeople participation in whatever
comes but the incentive not only the
knowledge of what is in the best
interest of the town but the incentive
for the town government is revenue and
if you do severe caps that's going to
affect the market which is going to
devalue prices which will decrease
Revenue
so that they're not at all predisposed
to doing this in fact I imagine it's
going to take quite the crisis in any
given town before a Town Council or a
select board is willing to do something
like this
representative benchputi
thank you Mr tip thank you
representative Reed for taking my
question
um
this
legislation the way you're saying it is
enabling legislation
if already something like this a similar
practice exists in a community
which is doing the best for their
Community
would this change their approach or
would would it enable
that Community to adopt this without
majorly changing their bylaw or
whilst I certainly have not researched
all 320 municipalities in the state I
feel confident in the idea that there is
no municipality currently doing this
because municipalities are not currently
able to do this and should they pass
such a bylaw they would almost certainly
be challenged by the property owners of
their town and taken to to a to the
Supreme Court to determine the
constitutionality and it's very clear
that they have to be enabled and it's
very clear that they have not been able
to do this so I am going to go out on a
limb a very very short easy strong Limb
and say no one is already doing this but
this does give those towns tools to to
do things like this
okay any more questions we have a lot of
testimony to go if there are any more
questions for representative Reed
seeing none I have one representative
Reed I just want to
um follow up on representative Powers
question just a simple yes or no
um the intent of the legislation that if
the property is sold
the Restriction goes with the property
so we're talking about restrictions on
properties not the owner yes correct yes
sir that's great thank you so much thank
you
okay uh next we have
anybody who's going to be testifying
please do state your name and um whether
you're for or against also just so you
know everybody get uh gets your
testimony concise we're going to limit
it to three minutes we have a lot of
cards and we've got a lot of bills to go
through today
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee for hearing my
testimony for the record my name is
Kathy Staub I represent Hillsboro 25
Ward 5 in Manchester
we in Manchester are facing an enormous
housing crisis
um
about 50 of the people who live in the
city of Manchester are renters a
significant number of them live in my
district
um currently in Hill in the state of New
Hampshire a two-bedroom apartment rents
for fifteen hundred dollars a month and
in Hillsborough County that number is
over eighteen hundred dollars a month
um and this is
um this this has had a a tremendous
impact on our community our community
has a range of people at different
income levels for example South Willow
Street we did our our planning documents
earlier this year and an economist came
in and said that the city of Manchester
South Willow Street Corridor generates
about 15 billion dollars of Commerce the
people who make that happen are retail
workers who are making anywhere between
twelve and fifteen dollars an hour which
is not enough to afford rent in the city
of Manchester
um
older people are also impacted since I
have been looking into this issue for
the last several years a number of
people have come to my attention retired
disabled people disabled veterans 75
year old woman who was being displaced
for
um because someone new bought her
apartment ended up couch surfing for
several years before we could find
housing for her so this is not limited
to young people it it is across the
board currently we have about 250 people
living on the street in Manchester and
you probably have seen the news about
the encampment in front of the families
in transition facility
um but there are hundreds more that are
living in cars or living in hotels
we just have a family in my neighborhood
that just moved in after spending
several years living in a hotel
um and other people are doubling up so
this is a huge crisis and
um it has had a devastating impact on
our on our city it doesn't just impact
the people who can't find housing it
impacts all of us because most of us
um
are are um are struck by the level of
human suffering of the people who are
living on the streets or living in
hotels
um you know we say well the people that
living on the streets are are mentally
ill or addicted to drugs well
um you have to think about cause and
effect
um
they may not have started out that way
but the stress of living on the streets
has caused them to turn to alcohol or
drugs in order to in order to survive
day to day
so you know you may hear a lot of uh
talk today about how the market will
solve the problem but that takes time
you know in Manchester currently our
city has
um on plans to develop hundreds and
hundreds of units of of affordable
housing but it'll be years before that
happens in the meantime people are dying
on the street they're dying in cars
and this would be a tremendous tool for
us that would enable the city of
Manchester
um you know to Stave off some of this
human suffering that we are seeing in
our community
and
um I would appreciate you know and I I
understand that there's a lot to it
unless having listened to um the sponsor
of the bill
um but I please you know take this
seriously and the the situation in the
in the Mount Washington Valley is
different than the situation in Keene or
Nashville or
um so please give our our elected
officials in our communities the ability
to um to do something because they at
this point they're just saying there's
nothing we can do thank you thank you
representative any questions
representative Stout
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
sure okay next uh I have Joanne McIntyre
from the New Hampshire Association
Association of Realtors again uh please
uh three minutes uh
Vice chair power will give you a
30-second warning we're going to have to
stick with this unfortunately we have a
lot of individuals
um so miss miss McIntyre go ahead good
morning my name is Joni McIntyre I'm a
realtor with Coldwell Banker J Hampe
Associates here in Concord I'm also the
president-elect of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors and I'm here
representing New Hampshire Realtors and
we oppose this bill
first Realtors certainly recognize the
impetus behind this legislation vacancy
rates across the state are less than one
percent and like housing costs rents
have been rising rapidly
throughout New Hampshire lower income
families are effectively priced out of
the housing market in most communities
even middle-income families find their
budgets stretched to provide adequate
housing for their families
however we think this bill could make
matters worse by constraining the
housing Supply even further and
therefore Realtors are opposed to it
the patchwork of ever-changing local
ordinances will not create fairer
housing market a fair housing market
instead it will reduce the quantity and
quality of available housing will
discourage new construction
increases increased rents for
unprotected tenants and create other
challenges for both landlords and
tenants
the trend nationally over the past
decade has been to move away from this
sort of rent stabilization measure
envisioned in HB 95.
municipalities currently have the
authority under State Statute to work
with developers in planning in the
planning stages to ensure a certain
number of units in an apartment complex
are retained as affordable
a developer might receive density bonus
or some other benefit
if they create such units
it is not it's not a perfect process
but for for-profit developers must
ensure a certain rate of return in order
to move forward with their development
other states with such rent
stabilization requirements have been
deferred have seen deferred maintenance
abandonment
lost tax revenues and widely varying
rents for similar Apartments
let's be honest in some communities
apartment developments are not even
welcome
it's frustrating to hear such concerns
about apartments since they are such a
vital and integral part of ensuring New
Hampshire has adequate Workforce
it is not a largely to suggest that if
hb95 becomes law some towns will use
this new statute to create ordinances
designed to dissuade developers from
coming into their community
fewer opportunities for apartments in
New Hampshire
will have devastating consequences
the answer to expanding housing Supply
is not more government regulations but
less we have to allow development to be
built more densely with faster approvals
I will also point out that Senate Bill
47 was heard in the other body yesterday
that bill sets up a commission to review
the lack of affordable housing options
and barriers to more density in
construction we think the solution this
bill seeks to address is is better
Suited to to the studies Commission
the problem is lack of inventory and we
fear this bill will make matters worse
people your testimony are there any
questions representative Gallagher
um so you mentioned other Solutions you
prefer
um such as allowing more denser building
so
yeah if we've got Bill if we pass bills
to do those as well
um wouldn't that cancel out any of the
negative effects you see from
uh you see from this bill having like
why can't we do both
studied and I think it's more important
to push for that increased density
representative Gilman go ahead
thank you Mr chair um I had the only
question I have uh you reference the
developers can take advantage of uh
density bonuses and and those kind of
things in their development of
properties so they have to provide
affordable units
is there anything that ties them to
keeping those units affordable or do
they are they allowed to just flip them
to whatever they want later
I I really don't know the answer to that
question I imagine the municipality
could could state that in their
you know in offering that to a developer
okay thank you
represents Davis
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I represent the city of Lebanon and
we have no shortage of developers coming
to our planning board wanting to build
apartment buildings
none of them intend to include
affordable units in those buildings
it's a matter of
in their parlance it doesn't pencil
you can't make a living if you have
affordable units in your building
I recognize and understand that this is
a gordian knot type of problem with lots
of different aspects but my question to
you is
when you're talking to developers and I
assume that you do as a real estate
agent or or somebody in this field
what do you say to them when they say
well I'd love to include affordable
units in my
450 unit building that I'm going for the
planning board to discuss but it doesn't
pencil
what's your response to that
if you mean it doesn't pencil at the end
of the day we can't we can't make our
money back
I think that's a a big part of the
problem right now I don't have an answer
for that because if a developer can't
rent those units for an amount that they
can make their money they're not going
to build and I think you're seeing that
happening
um
I
I don't know I don't know what the
answer to that is their margins are very
close
um costs are so high but I do believe
that if we have more more inventory
um
lower lower cost units will come
available if and that will may allow for
more people to have you know sort of a
supply and demand situation you can't
you can't keep that inventory
so tight
that there's there's no room for more
people
representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony and taking my question as
a professional in in the field what
would you what do you determine what
affordable housing is
you hear affordable housing affordable
housing what is it is it relation to the
size of the unit uh what what determines
what the unit is to go up the rental
well I I I do know there's a number for
Workforce housing that that should be
and I can't tell you that that formula
right now but but when I talk about
affordable housing I talk about what
what people can get into from an amount
that they can afford um
in different places it will it will mean
different things
um
I do know that thirty two hundred
dollars a month in I have a tenant who
are not a tenant but a somebody looking
to buy thirty two hundred dollars a
month is not affordable
um and I heard somebody else say that
they had some you know 1800 in
Manchester
um
or some people that would be affordable
or some people that would not be
affordable so I mean I I think the the
bottom line is more inventory is what's
most important
thank you for your testimony thank you
Mr chairman
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question my question is uh increasing
density is one tool one prong of the
tool to address the issue
but currently
is there an enabling legislation if a
developer chooses to keep under for
example if there is uh inclusionary
zoning law in a particular Community if
they build over 50 units so they can
build under 50 units and not actually do
that so are there legislations that
currently exist
not give incentive for the developer
to add more density
in that so inventory is reduced so would
I would this combat that kind of a
negating uh
I don't really know if there's that type
of legislation I I really can't answer
that
yes representative lasalles
yes over here
thanks for taking my question
uh with respect to supply and demand the
certainly a cut in the supply of
apartment uh Apartments uh if the demand
is uh is stable then that's going to
cause the Market Force will cause uh
there to be an increase in rent what is
the impact as a real estate agent what
is the impact of people
turning their rental units into
short-term vrb
that sort of thing do you see that here
in Concord and what's your experience as
a real estate agent uh across the state
so I generally work in this area in
Concord
and I can honestly say I have not seen
an impact of that on the Concord rental
market
um that that's my experience only
representative Gallagher
so
um
back back to the
negative effects uh uh
you
were talking about so if those negative
effects do occur the municipalities
could just then
repeal these bylaws again then couldn't
they
I guess they could I guess if that's
what the legislation says
thank you thank you for your testimony
thank you very much
okay
um we are enforcing the three minutes
just so everybody here is aware
um one
one uh comment that I forgot to mention
at the very beginning uh those of you
who
are submitting testimony by sending it
to the email all committee members just
so you know that is not submitted
testimony that goes into the file you
have to go to the portal and I can't
tell you exactly where that is but you
got to go to the portal for the
testimony for it to become part of the
official record okay
but
yes representative 11. good morning Mr
chair and
and find the portal on the general court
website easy to find very good there's
your answer
um next we have uh
uh not sure the first name but uh last
name Cornell from the nhla
good morning thank you for hearing my
testimony today my name is Kirsten
Cornell and I'm an attorney at New
Hampshire legal assistance and I'm here
in support of this bill today
and as part of my job I work with
low-income tenants as a housing attorney
who oftentimes are facing evictions
we have up to 20 cases per week right
now many times half of which are based
on an increase in rent that is at times
fifth an increase of 50 percent I've
seen a doubling of the amount of rent
that's being charged
this is resulting in not only
homelessness and not only people having
nowhere to go
it's also resulting in deaths and this
is not uncommon
this bill is about local control
it's about municipalities being able
to look at what is happening in their
communities and balance that with the
requirements that they have under
another statute which is RSA 165 the
local welfare statute which requires
cities to relieve and maintain the
residents in their municipalities if
they are to become homeless if they are
to need assistance with utilities and
things like that
as
residents of municipalities increasingly
face homelessness or increasingly face
rents that are far exceeding their
income that places an economic burden on
the municipality in order to relieve and
maintain those residents
this bill would allow municipalities to
balance the costs that they're facing
against the
regulations that they are putting into
place locally that again as has been
pointed out by a number of folks can be
repealed if an emergency situation does
no longer exist
there was a question about whether or
not this is an emergency situation or
what is an emergency situation there
have been at least two deaths due to
exposure to cold in the state of New
Hampshire just in the last few weeks
I have spoken personally with at least
two tenants in the last two weeks who
have told me that they have not been
able to find an affordable place to go
and because of that they're leaving the
state
if we want to have a state that grows
and develops
diversely and including you know
including diversity across age
we need to ensure that there are places
for people to live
um I thank you for hearing my testimony
today
um in terms of affordable housing I
think that we need to look at the
average minimum of what people are being
paid what they're able to afford and how
we want people to live
thank you thank you for your testimony
uh
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question
um are you a few years ago
um municipalities were given a number
for somebody houseless I won't call them
homeless but no roof over what they had
what it costs the
municipalities to take care of somebody
who doesn't have a it was a hundred
thousand dollars a year with all the
support services that has to be plugged
in do you have any number at this point
I do not have a number at this point
um I imagine that I can get that
information if the committee would
appreciate that
thank you just as a reminder for
everybody on our uh representative L
word just try to keep our questions from
this committee specifically to
the subject at hand and also I'm going
to remind you we have a bunch more to go
a lot of people testifying if the point
has already been made if you can skip
over that so we can get through these
bills we've got at least another eight
or ten people to go representative L
Word
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um what type of expertise do you foresee
members of the governing body having to
have to develop these kind of bylaws
legal economic what
you mean in terms of the those who would
developed the bylaws is that what kind
of expertise uh I imagine that they
would need to know their Community they
would need to know
um what the vacancy rate is what the
cost of living is what a family needs in
order to be able to live safely and with
dignity in their community
I have a partner
do you have a follow-up yes sir go ahead
would this be done by a community survey
would they have to hire an expert to
come in to evaluate I mean this is
rather subjective
I can't answer a question as to what
municipalities will do certainly I
imagine they could draw information from
experts
um but I'm not in a position to State
what a Municipality Water would not do
thank you so much
thank you for your testimony next we
have
Brandon Lemay
hey my name is Brandon Lemay I am from
Manchester New Hampshire and I'm
representing rights and democracy uh we
are a member-led organization looking to
make Grassroots change at the local
state and federal level
um I want to be really quick today
because I feel like we've already gone
through a lot of the details of this
piece of legislation I'm speaking in uh
support of this uh and I want to kind of
reframe this conversation here because I
want to talk about another aspect that
this bill could actually help out with
and that is with making sure that we are
keeping up with housing standards in
terms of like quality of the housing so
for instance uh in Manchester where
currently they are packing up the
biggest homeless encampment in the state
right now
could you stop your testimony again
could you please keep it to the subject
matter of the bill homelessness and yeah
please keep it to the bill yes yes thank
you representative uh yeah so I just
want to say that um this bill could be
used to make sure that uh that cities
and towns can enforce proper housing
standards so for instance a lot of the
tenants that I work with are facing
things like improper electrical wiring
uh unsafe Plumbing that's leaking
causing mold and unfortunately there's
very little that the city of Manchester
can do to actually make sure that
landlords are keeping up with the
quality of their housing so I would like
to state that uh basically making sure
that people stay inside their Apartments
is one of the best ways to make sure
that they do not become homeless and in
order to keep housing stock available uh
it could be really beneficial to the
city of Manchester Chester to make sure
that we're enforcing housing quality
standards and I just want to emphasize
this bill is all about local control and
I don't believe that a rental practice
could make sense for North Conway and
Manchester we need to make sure that our
local leaders are setting standards that
make sense for their communities
sometimes I think that there are
standards that wouldn't make sense all
across the state and this would just let
us us work with our aldermen to be able
to work on solutions that work for our
community and for us
thank you thank you representative
yukela
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um there was some talk before about
um the evidence that someone might need
to be able to put in a good
um bylaw
um is there anything in this law or that
would require such following of evidence
or
um
or would someone be able to make a bad
law
um by law using this language even
though they were advise that it would be
bad for their Community thank you for
the question
I mean I believe that anybody can make a
bad law
um but I think that I trust people to be
able to work with their local officials
and if their local officials make bad
laws then we can show them that on
Election Day
so you know more questions thank you for
your testimony thank you next we have
Jane Huff or have like
I I just don't mess it up
okay good morning my name is Jane Hague
and I live in a 1573 Union Street in
Manchester and I'm a member of the
Manchester housing Alliance we're an
activist group
and we have been attempting to
understand the problem with housing
specifically in Manchester
and I think that I'm going to try to be
really brief because I think
representative Reed did a wonderful job
of introducing this bill and everything
that it's about and I just want to
emphasize that really we do have a
housing crisis in the state I've been
going to things like the business and
industry Council luncheons
and informational sessions and they
recognize that there's no affordable
housing for workers to live in that the
rental vacancy rate
in the state is less than one percent
and um so I think that this first of all
really is a housing crisis
um I do agree with the spokespersons for
the Realtors more apartments are needed
I think we need more cities and towns to
step up to the plate and allow for
construction and in Manchester we have
seen
approvals by the Planning and Zoning
commissions to build more housing but
it's going to be a year or two really be
realistically before it's actually
complete and ready for occupancy
and in the meantime people are being
pushed out of their apartments and are
living in cars if they have a car or on
couches if they have a friend
so as a business and industry Council
says businesses need workers workers
need someplace to live that they can
afford
um
the idea that if all these units come
online rents will suddenly become more
affordable it's really magical thinking
I mean really I think it's up to the
legislature here to do something to
frankly the affordable units don't
pencil out and I think that we're going
to have to come up with systems to
really subsidize developers to build
more but meanwhile I think this bill
does a lot to enable local control as
representative Reid said the local level
is where
some of these rules
um about rents need to take place that
can can serve during an emergency that
we're having for the next two or three
or four years and then if it's not
needed anymore that they can be repealed
um I think it's especially egregious
when
um buildings that have been long time
rentals on sometimes by older Manchester
or Statewide landlords people from
outside the state come in and buy them
up
and raise the rents to as much as they
think that they can get and push out
longtime tenants even elderly and
disabled tenants
um I think we should really all be
appalled and try to think about what we
could do about that so thank you very
much
thank you for your testimony
seeing no questions thank you uh next we
have
Nick Kerman or Horman
okay
do you have written testimony
two pages
thank you
thank you very much for taking my
testimony my name is Nick Norman I'm
with the apartment association of New
Hampshire and I lead a legislative
Initiative for landlord tenant law
across the state
we send out weekly updates to somewhere
in the range of 3 400
subscribers and a member of many
landlord associations across the state
I've been a landlord for 35 years I have
48 units I have a good amount of
expertise in this I also work with the
national Apartment Association at the
federal level this is a gigantic issue
that landlords and landlord associations
are wrestling with in an across the
entire country
so first I want to tell you that
we have an essential problem of supply
and demand not enough Supply
and too much demand
so what I want you to
know
is that if you're looking at
um
if you're looking at helping to solve
what is being called the housing crisis
and you're not looking at increasing
Supply
then you are looking in the wrong place
we need to create increase supply of
housing
that's the essential problem if you do
anything else then you have not
increased the supply of housing you will
exacerbate the problem
the market is is a force
it has its own life and dynamic you
can't squeeze a part of the force over
here and expect everything else to just
stay in place something's going to
happen
so I'm going to just highlight a couple
things and I hope that you'll ask me a
lot of questions
we need to have the state working on
incentives to increase unit production
they rent control absolutely a failed
concept city after city after City
for decades
places that have had rent control
ban it because it didn't work
St Paul Minnesota in 2022 instituted
their own rent control
new construction was down by 80 percent
right after that
we don't need to disincentify new
construction we need to incentify new
construction in more affordable housing
if you put in rent control then there's
no ability to adjust for increased costs
and as a property owner you can't know
what the incoming increased costs are
um
foreign
if you have
a situation like what's proposing this
bill in different towns with different
regulations and then you have tenants
challenging
the rent increases and you've got this
gigantic problem of knowing what every
Town's regulation is courts are already
overwhelmed I don't think you want to
have courts to have to
know every regulation in every town
across the board of economists
overwhelmingly agree that price controls
on rent are ineffective
counterproductive lead to Serious
negative impacts on the housing market
housing stock deteriorates there are 37
states in the United States that have
preemptions on rent control
it discourages new rental housing
imagine uh you know what happens is
a lot of times you'll see Property
Owners selling out and they'll sell it
like a mobile home park could could sell
their mobile home if you've got rent
control what will happen to all those
mobile home renters
there's some studies in here that are
encourage you to look at
um
17 of them
there's a there's a summary from the
national Department Association showing
17 different studies in the past have
always shown rent control to fail
um I could talk for a long time but I
know there's a lot of people I have a
lot of expertise on this my contact info
is at the Top If you don't ask me a
question today I highly encourage you to
contact me email me so we can talk about
this issue and I'd be very happy to take
questions and I have some answers for
some of the questions that were asked
already
actually uh we're gonna unless there's
any questions uh I will encourage
everybody to read that and contact you
you're certainly open to uh
representative 11.
thank you Mr chair
um and thank you for taking my question
thank you for your testimony I just want
to know if you are aware that the New
Hampshire Housing Authority partners
with
tenants in mobile home parks that have
gone on the market and rather than
selling to a private owner
oftentimes and I don't have a number in
front of me
the tenant group will be able to buy
that mobile home park and turn it into a
co-op where the tenants stay and have
control yeah I'm aware that there are
certain of those regulations thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman a couple of quick
questions how many units do you
currently uh myself personally have 48
units okay and how do you determine what
the appropriate rent is and make a
reasonable profit uh so what we so what
we do in my company and I think it's
true for almost any landlord is when I
have a good tenant
then we give them a very small increase
when I have a problem tenant they have a
higher increase
and what happens is over the years
I've got tenants that have been in my
apartment for longer than I've owned
them I've had many candidates that have
been there 20 years 10 years
many that are 10 to 15 years all those
tenants of ours end up with rents that
are probably in the range of anywhere
from one to four hundred dollars less
than the market rate
when a tenant leaves then we put the
rent to the market rate of course
okay
seeing no more questions thank you for
your testimony
next we have uh is it Elliott Berry
oh yes please do uh I'm reminded that
when you speak say whether you're
opposed or for
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the first time my name is
Elliot Berry and for the first time in
47 years I come before you as a private
citizen for 47 years I pray I was a
housing specialist at New Hampshire
legal assistance where I represented
thousands thousands of tenants
I want to just make one thing that I
hope is clear whatever decision you make
on this bill please don't make it on the
basis of whether rent control is a good
or a bad idea
the question is is it such a horrible
idea that the town shouldn't even be
allowed to consider it that's really
what's before you today there are people
uh rent control has been attacked so
many times I'll just add a few things
that just in the last few years our
neighbors in Portland Maine have adopted
it notwithstanding all of the anti-rent
control propaganda based so often on
studies that were contracted for by real
estate owners and developers in uh with
the state of Oregon has adopted
Statewide rent control
they're in the state or in the states of
New York and California literally
millions of tenants have been protected
so often senior citizens persons and to
say yeah persons of with disabilities
have been protected by these laws where
otherwise they clearly would have been
priced out of homes in which they've
lived in for ages
but I think the debate needs to happen
on a market-by-market municipality by
municipality Portsmouth might consider
it Berlin's never going to consider it
um I also should take a moment to
apologize because if I had been a better
young lawyer maybe would we wouldn't be
here I actually was lead counsel in
defending the town of Allenstown who
actually passed a mobile home park rent
Control Ordinance I couldn't make
convince the Supreme Court that the town
of Allentown had the ability to do that
so I'm sorry we wouldn't be wasting your
time if I had been able to beat that let
me tell you though what I have actually
seen to give you an idea of why this is
even coming here today
these are actual clients that I've had
uh KB in Nashua got a sudden notice of a
500 rent increase Daniel B his rent was
increased from fifteen hundred fifty
dollars to three thousand dollars so
there were two other uh Manchester
residents who had the same thing in that
complex a JT in hanaker a twelve hundred
Ten Dollar rent increase Liz Marie I
forgot to note where she lived 950 rent
increase a Lake State in Nashua 550
increase think about if you all I think
probably most of you are homeowners if
you got 60 days 45 days 30 days notice
that your mortgage payment was going to
go up 500 or fifteen hundred dollars
what would that do to you and you are
literally talking about people who are
being dispersed God knows where in a
state with a with a vacancy rate of one
half of one percent being dispersed all
over the state or out of the state these
are very very terrible times let me just
add one more thing when you talk about
rent control it's not one thing it can
be whatever is designed subject to
constitutional limits of due process New
Hampshire's right to property uh and
so it could be you could exempt new
construction you could exempt small you
know landlords with small Holdings you
could do there are so many different
ways that this can be done and there are
little literally about a hundred local
current ordinances across the country
that decision makers can use uh to pick
as models with such local modifications
as um you deem appropriate so again I
just urge you
um and again they can Sunset them too
which is probably the most important
thing
um so the bottom line is whether you
think about yeah a little excess of what
we're trying to a lot so we're going to
hold your testimony there is there any
questions representative majority thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I said on my local planning
board did I hear did I hear correctly
and understand that either the select
board which I also sit on or the
planning board could allow for a
variance for a landlord or a waiver
against the increase based on certain
conditions well I know that's not what I
was suggesting but the ordinance itself
could be structured to guarantee and
should be a fair net operating income
for the if it doesn't do that then it's
probably going to be unconscious it will
be unconstitutional so but any waivers
would be in the ordinance or any
adjustments would be within the Contours
of the ordinance
representative Keller
thank you thank you for taking the
question you uh criticized some studies
that might have been
um
um contracted by real estate firms do
you know of any or do you have any uh
studies to provide the committee that
were contracted by renters
I should uh probably more by academics
but I could certainly I don't know off
the top of my head but I'd be very happy
to get that information to you thank you
and but again I'm just not saying it's
whether it's good or bad the question is
whether it's so bad that it ought to be
verbose
thank thank you for your testimony okay
next we have uh Jessica marjason
we're going to move on representative
okay sorry
good morning
my name is Jessica marjason I am here
um representing myself I am from
Manchester New Hampshire and I am for
this bill
the reasons I am for this bill
um could you could you pull that
microphone a little closer too so we can
hear you better I apologize
I am a tenant organizer with Granite
State organizing project where I run a
tenant Clinic every Wednesday so I see
firsthand constantly how this would help
many communities I also am helping
organize Westgate Salem tenants in Salem
and I see how Salem operates different
from Manchester I've helped those in
Ossipee with my clinic and I see how
their resources are different from our
town in Manchester every town across our
state is widely different with resources
available for the City Welfare Offices
in what I am seeing across the state is
um a lot of the homeless shelters filled
so this is why it would help I'm also on
the Manchester housing commission why
this would help me in the commission
with my role is I am I've been asking
what units do we have in our town what
do we need because I feel that a
majority of our naturally occurring
affordable housing was decimated by
predatory landlords with the renovation
addictions we experienced over the last
two years we sit on numbers that we had
in our head two years ago but failed to
realize half of those were wiped out
with this we need new numbers and I
can't get new numbers from the
assessor's office either because the
assessor sends out a survey only a few
of those respond I have nothing to go to
to see the numbers of what our city has
and what we desperately need
um I also created and helped organize
and run the
Granite State tenants Association we
have come together we are 60 plus strong
currently new are getting added every
week we meet the second Saturday of
every month but I get to see residents
from across our state and they tell me
what's happening in their City another
thing that has not been mentioned is
fraud this bill could help with fraud I
have one client that I just met with
recently and she's coming to my clinic
today when I go back to the office her
rent was raised from 2200 to 3 800
because she had the nherap the New
Hampshire emergency rental assistance
program that offered rental assistance
to many of our residents that could not
afford the ever increasing rent
how this could help is this landlord
took this person's rent from 2200 a
month to 3 800 a month to be able to get
the extra money while they could and
luckily through text messages let her
know that after the program was done he
would lower her back down to 2200 a
month
being able to
set things give them more time they
couldn't quickly just change it our
rents are so high my tenants don't have
enough time to find something
Manchester's 0.3 for vacancy everyone
keeps mentioning below one it's point
three our county is 0.4 and it's not
that much different when you go around
our state
so each City or municipality being able
to step forth what they need is highly
beneficial for many different reasons
you have any questions please feel free
to contact me
thank you for your testimony thank you
seeing no questions
next we have Kathy Holmes
thank you Kathy Holmes I am
against this bill and you could write my
name down on this Norman's paper because
I second everything he said he has 48
units and my husband and I have three
one duplex and a house
um but so
um I can make my two minutes probably
one minute because of his writing and I
want you to watch out for the buzzwords
used by the other side crisis and
emergency and we need to speedily do
something
these
these don't
um they're only meant to motivate people
emotionally and we know whenever
government gets involved things get
ruined and the more power you give to
government whether it's local or big and
a lot of these um extra costs are from
DC the big government and the energy
costs what's the landlord supposed to do
if they're paying the energy bills in
the rent then things have to happen
because landlords can't Subs can't be
the socialism that you want
so
um
I think I could I could quit there
thank you for your testimony
seeing no questions thank you
uh next we have
I'm sorry
I have no idea what it says uh I said
Audette
last name Audette
uh lives on Autumn Street in Manchester
when you come up just make sure you
state your name I couldn't read it
sorry about that I write worse than the
doctor
that's why I like my computer uh I'm
Glenn Willette I live at 112 Auburn
Street Apartment A in Manchester New
Hampshire
um representing myself and I'm a member
of the Granite State rental tenant
association
let me say something that has not been
said
if there is a village in your community
a whole neighborhood that's owned by one
landlord
with two or three hundred apartments in
it
and they sell it to an outside person
and that outside person kicks everybody
out because they're going to renovate
them all and you have an option when it
comes back on board to come back but
your rent goes up 300 percent what
happens to that renter
give another example
I pay rent
I had three heart attacks this year and
pneumonia I lost a lot of income because
I couldn't go to work
graciously I'm back at work but I have a
a
seasonal jobs from January to April I do
very little work there's no work
you still have to pay the rent the rent
went up three hundred dollars in
September this January they tried to
re-raise the rent another 200 yet we
have a lease
and I'm on Section Eight Section 8 isn't
going to pay no more because their their
contract says once a year
so there is predatory not by everyone
but it does exist and there is fraud
this has got to stop this may not solve
the entire solution but it's going to
stop a lot of it and when it comes to
raising rent or not
if you have too much unaffordable rent
that people can't afford to pay
you have to have in Manchester so much
so that other towns and cities in New
Hampshire and across the country send
their people to Manchester
so it becomes the city has the burden
and what does that do it raises your
taxes so for those of you who can't
can't afford to pay your taxes here it
goes that's not the solution
our state constitution States precisely
that every Community must take care of
its own people
we now have kids being born in tense and
left there
the state has failed a lot of our
children
because of poverty it's time for change
this is a beginning so yes I am in favor
of this it doesn't solve all there used
to be a time in Manchester that if you
build an apartment building you could
negotiate how many affordable housing
you would have that doesn't exist
anymore so there is no affordable
housing what is Affordable if your rent
goes up above 50 percent and your income
does not change my incomes come down two
years in a row yet my rent is going up
tremendously that means eventually I
will become homeless thank you any
questions thank you for your testimony
uh representative true 11
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
roulette for taking my question I'm
wondering if you could just tell me
what's included in your rent currently
uh
uh the only utility that's included is
the Heat and it's neighbor works it's a
federal housing
it's I live in the federal housing
project
rental only the heat I have to pay
electricity if it's gone up over a
hundred and something percent
thank you very much you're welcome
seeing uh no other questions uh I
believe this will be our last testimony
uh Philip Sherman
Mr chair members of the committee I'll
do a significant surgery on my comments
and submit them in writing later my wife
and I own 10 units in the Upper Valley
which we have bought one at a time since
1989. we don't get a choice at this
point as to which municipality we're
going to invest in we're in it our costs
keep going up and regulating our income
without regulating our cost makes no
more sense than regulating the price of
eggs or why not regulate the price that
you make on a profit selling a single
family home
I'll speak against this motion for the
main reason that rent control just does
not work and I'll get into the details
in my written uh statements many many of
them have been to me this morning but I
would note that our friends South of the
Border in Massachusetts repealed their
rent control laws in 1994. unfortunately
bad ideas tend to pop back up in every
generation and here we go again
the solution is more units more
construction and only more units as was
stated previously if we don't work on
the supply the rest of this just
restricts Supply it doesn't increase
I also said as the chair of the of the
New Hampshire building code review board
we have passed amendments this year
they're in the ratification process now
to reduce the cost of some alterations
permitting lower cost changes to
residential uses uh everybody seems to
agree that much of the problem sits on
the zoning side so I would suggest that
that's where the solution may be
and I'll call it a day for for now
thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative 11.
thank you Mr chair I'm not trying to be
a pain thank you so much for taking my
question
um do you think there's more than one
solution to this problem
I can only look at this from the view of
a small business person me and my wife
who bought these units based on our
expectation that we would be free to
charge what we need to charge
I would mention that our rents
didn't even keep up with inflation for
several years and they spiked in the
last couple of years
but if you draw that curve from when we
bought them until now and they're
probably closer to inflation
so that's part of the problem much like
the prices of single-family homes
thank you very much you're welcome
I see no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony
are there any other pink cards that have
not been turned in or anybody who wishes
to speak
why don't you come up and uh if you if
you've turned one in
just come and testify and then fill out
another card for us please
um hi my name is Kate West and I am in
support of this bill
uh to me it does often seem as though uh
property owners
will say you know we don't want
regulations because it will impact our
profit but when you can afford to own
multiple properties I think that you do
have a responsibility to run them in a
way that is helpful to your community
not exploitive folks that often are like
you can't regulate this
usually are trying to exploit the people
around them that's why the regulations
are necessary
it also again if you cannot own more
than one property without
exploiting the people in your community
maybe you shouldn't own those properties
landlords feel very comfortable saying
if you can't afford to pay rent maybe
you shouldn't have a place to live but
don't often apply that logic to whether
or not they should own more than one
place
to live
so unfortunately you know I have
a strong
urge to ask our community members with
wealth and property to really think
about
what they're doing when they are raising
the cost to be housed to a point where
folks that
maybe make the minimum wage in our
community to the point where they can't
afford to be housed
uh so thank you
thank you seeing no more I have no more
pink cards make sure you fill out a pink
card for us please I'll close the
hearing on HV 95 uh let's take five
minutes and then we'll come back and get
going on uh HP 422.
foreign
taking good notes there John
okay folks we're gonna get going on the
next hearing uh representative Reed if
you're out in the hall you need to come
in
I serve
and I'm going to open up the hearing on
hb422fn and welcome representative Reed
thank you again Mr chair and thank you
again honorable members of the committee
I don't think I actually I think I
forgot to formally introduce myself last
time my name is Ellen Reed and I
represent Newmarket and new fields
rockinghamton
um so this bill before you would simply
add to the
um registry of deeds that we currently
have on the county level a registry of
rents
um and
the reason this is necessary and I I
won't repeat my testimony in terms of
the problem from from the last bill and
I went to Mr chair
um but we do have a predatory situation
right now where very frequently
um people who buy these properties are
raising the rents I think I told you in
my town a thousand dollar raises were
happening but you've heard other
testimony to that so I'll leave it to
you to understand that that's happening
but that it's predatory in the nature
that there those increases are being
blamed on this nebulous thing called the
market which I understand there are
obviously real Market forces at work as
with everything in our economy but when
that's a very convenient cover and it
turns out you are in fact paying well
over Market
um rates for the property you're buying
and yet still
increasing the rents on people
then effectively what we call renovation
evicting them for renovations and then
doing renovations and increasing it
again and you're still making a healthy
healthy profit then the question becomes
so if you're already paying over Market
rates how is this the market
how is this the market and what part is
predatory what part is opportunistic
what parts being blamed on the market
when it's not actually simply an
increase of cost could you speak
specifically yes to this place I was
speaking to the need for it thank you
um so while we do have already a very
close
um following of the information every
single property in existence
is
logged we know every single property is
capable of being sold or may be sold in
the future capable of being bought and
so we have all of that information
whenever it's changed hands we don't
have any of that information for the
rental amounts and if you think about it
in general Mark it's kind of weird it's
like the only thing that's kind of
secretive in a lot of ways and generally
when we think about the economy we know
what for example the average price of
eggs is or the average gallon of gas or
milk or what have you but we don't have
nice data to to go to in order to follow
what rental amounts actually are and be
able to discern the difference between
what is market and what is simply
opportunistically blamed on the market
and I do want to raise a point that was
raised earlier but because it's it's
relative to this
um some of that predatory behavior that
this bill would seek to be able to
identify by seeing what the rents are is
some of that uh Behavior I think one of
the representatives call it rents
thinking Behavior but essentially what
was called fraud which is we have a
number of
um
non-profits that help people if they are
in rental crisis and the landlords know
this and so they increase the rent
knowing that those tenants can then go
get that assistance and in fact the
landlord specifically in my town that
was causing so much problems was
specifically referring people to that
new every bit everything that those uh
those programs provided how long they
would provide it for how much it could
be renewed so this would also this this
is in in essence is transparency at its
core it's simple transparency and
anytime you bring something out into the
sunlight you can help to uncover and
therefore combat fraud like that
so as I said we already do this with
property ownership it wouldn't be that
much more data being dealt with and all
of it would be self-reported by the
landlords themselves so it's not
um like somebody going and finding out
this information it's filed by the
landlords so uh it wouldn't be an an
onerous increase in duties and whatever
was increased that needed to be handled
in terms of uh labor can easily be
overcome by a very modest fee for filing
um I would imagine something like five
dollars would be enough for all the
rental units if they're all filed would
be enough to cover the extra paperwork
necessary so like I said every single
property is already registered not all
properties are rented right so you're
talking about fewer than the total
number that they already do
so I do I have become aware that someone
a detractor uh said that they actually I
think it's kind of funny that they
actually
um said they thought this would add to
price fixing when that's in fact the
behavior that this seeks to uncover with
transparency
um so the effect that we're experiencing
right now is in effect price fixing but
true price fixing is when two
competitors go behind closed doors and
agree to keep their prices High because
there's no incentive for them to have
lower prices and as long as they agree
to not compete and try to out price each
other they can keep it high specifically
with housing this is particularly
effective because you have people over a
barrel there's no uh housing is an
inelastic cost people have to have it so
there's no like well I don't need your
product so I'm just gonna go away you
know you have to have it and you have to
pay it so because of that that this
transparency is actually required that's
the actual reason it's required in terms
of actually people getting together and
making those price fixing deals that's
not you know nothing is happening now to
prevent that from happening and nothing
in this bill would increase that
happening
um
so I think I've gone through almost all
my points here I'm happy to open up to
questions
representative L Word
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Reed
the bill only lists
maybe two data points that would be
collected to formulate this registry and
that being the monthly amount of rent
and I I assume the address right what
other data points do you foresee being
collected so a county could choose to
collect square footage of the unit
um potentially could choose to select a
key number of amenities if they so chose
that would be up to the discretion of
the county but at a bare minimum because
we do already have square footage for a
lot of addresses anyway
um address and Rental amount would be
the most important pieces
may I follow up Mr chairman
uh go ahead follow up
so essentially If I'm renting a unit
someone can go log on to registry of
deeds or go to the office look up the
address and find out how much I'm paying
in rent correct and that correct and
that would be very in theory unless your
landlord was doing something
off thank you but that is the very
similar to how you can currently look up
and see when a property was last sold to
the current owner and how much they paid
thank you
represent uh representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking a question uh
I don't see any enforceability in in
this or punitive actions should somebody
not register do you have any
anticipation for that or any have you
thought about that
so as you know when you're submitting
bills if you add punitive things it
makes it less likely to pass and then
there's a lot of arguments about that
those punishments being onerous in order
to keep this as simple as possible I
didn't add it it is something I thought
about
um of course at all times we have civil
action available to us
thank you
representative Brown
thank you chairman
um my question is this act shall take
effect in 60 days have you reviewed this
with the counties about how they would
enact this and
and put this into their system already
because a lot of our systems are have
difficulties already
I have not specific and I that's right I
feel so rude uh talking to the side of
the speaker but
um I have not conferred with any
particular County on the limitations of
their systems having said that they
already have to deal with every single
property in their County so I don't
think that this would be much more data
that they have to add thank you
representative Tetro do you have a
question
thank you Mr chair and thanks for being
here to answer our questions
um
just for
how many rental units does Manchester
have
how many rental units in Manchester I
don't represent Manchester I represent
New Market in new fields and admittedly
I can't tell you exactly how many rental
units are in New Market either but um
it's in the order of hundreds
okay
go ahead thank you
um
sorry
I don't see where this would accomplish
what your looking for it looks like a
I'm sorry I'm expressing an opinion here
and I shouldn't be
um
how do you see
municipalities
oh I'm assuming you're going to have
municipalities collect this information
in the registry of deeds or counties
um
who's paying for this
so thank you for allowing me to clarify
um so no I don't foresee municipalities
or really anyone in the active sense
collecting the information I foresee
landlords being that it's a requirement
and statute without a punitive uh stick
so to speak but landlords uh obeying the
law and self-reporting to the county so
not the towns but the county the county
already collects information on all
properties in terms of ownership and
whenever they're sold not every property
that's owned gets rented so you're
talking about a smaller number of
properties that are actually rented out
so it's less than what the current
registry contains thank you
oh and the fee to answer the last part
of your question if the county so it
shows although it's not a lot of extra
work they could Institute a small filing
fee to cover that extra paperwork
representative
thank you Mr chair before I have a
question I have a question for the chair
uh the blue sheet do you uh let us know
after each bill how many opposed and how
many
that would be very helpful thank you
that's a good reminder thank you thank
you
um my question thank you for taking my
question representative Reed
currently many of the assessing uh
assessor's office do have online where
we can check the property
so would that would this require
opt-in if we as an owner can
you know say the intention changes from
owner occupied to rental oh yes I I
completely foresee that and of course as
with all bills there's certain things
that you put in statute and certain
things you leave to the administrative
level I would obviously presume that
that is included in you know they
already have owner occupied data so if
it's being rented out that's what I want
to add but if it reverts back to owner
occupied then there would be a method
for that
foreign
I am not in any way restricting the data
that that the counties are collecting I
am saying that they need to at least set
a bare minimum collect rental amounts
representative yokella
thank you thank you for taking the
question it's kind of two parts
um the uh
the registry of deeds is like keeping
track of like legal documents
um and so I wonder what type of legal
document you think that
um
would be required or are you thinking
that this is just like a form that they
have to fill out and have notarized or
something like that and then given to
the
I wouldn't even foresee it needing to be
notarized it would be the creation of a
legal document if you'd like to look at
it that way and and to representative
Magnum Booty's uh point I think she said
something about online to the extent
that counties already have the ability
to collect the current data online that
would be an easy thing for them to
increase on their website just say if
you are a rent if you rent out a
property in this County you have to
yearly put in the amount that you're
renting in the address you're renting it
at so it would just be input of data
it's you know if you want to look at it
as a form or the creation of a document
yeah follow up go ahead and follow up
thank you um
if it's not notarized or anything like
that
um could uh what would be the control I
guess for me putting in a form that says
you put in uh you know you're you're now
renting your house for five million
dollars a month how is that enforced
yeah I mean back to the enforcement
principle there's a reason I didn't want
to come down like too specific because
it tends to hurt bills to do that but
having said that just like every form
that you sign ever it's usually
something above that goes I state that
all the above information is true to the
best of my knowledge and then you sign
it so that's uh or an electronic
signature when you do things online but
that's um I mean I'm filing for
unemployment right now and then I have
to do an electronic signature this is
the same thing
kind of a new I would like to ask a
question on a new different topic not a
follow-up
we'll go to a different come back come
back representative Guthrie yes thank
you
sorry thank you for taking my question
thank you Mr chairman is this uh bill
uh a a an attempt to correct bad conduct
it's an attempt to get the data
necessary to identify the Bad actors and
the bad conduct so I not correct but
identify
thank you thank you Mr chairman
representative 11. thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative Reed for
taking my question
um you just answered part of it the rest
of it is can you can you give me an idea
of besides collecting the data
what else this is
um what your intent is to file this bill
and the benefit to the public
so I I think I was clear that the the
collection of data for transparency's
sake I mean somebody had said something
about like well why is why is housing so
special we have all these other products
but housing is almost everybody's
certainly low to moderate but most
people's number one expense and it's
absolutely required so getting that
transparency on something that's that
vital to individuals to communities is
important so I mean I don't have any
other motive in that other than what
I've already expressed that collecting
that data for transparency's sake so
that we can see when actors are being
predatory and what it really is truly
the market
uh thank you may I have a follow-up Mr
chair you may go ahead follow up
um following up
full disclosure I'm a real estate broker
in my other life I have been for 35
years and when people come to me as a
buyer or a seller I generally don't deal
with rentals I mean I talk to them and
give them information and refer them to
someone who can help them
what I want to say is the
the buyer may come with that tax card on
which is recorded what it sold for when
it sold oftentimes it doesn't matter one
wit because the market has changed so
how will this help a renter
to see what is really fair and what is
really not fair in regards to rental
prices right so for example if you can
see that all the comparables the
comparables in the area are renting for
1200 and then one guy comes in and it's
1800 and that's an exaggerated uh
example because what we're seeing
instead is you know somebody comes in
says it's 1200 sorry it's the mark and
then the next person does 13 and the
next person does 14 and it kind of goes
like that and what I was referring to as
effective price fixing not actual behind
closed doors price fixing
um but if for to use the exaggerated
example if you see that it's not lining
up that the rinse is not lining up in
that particular owner has a pattern of
doing that then you can start to
identify you know why is that person
doing that is there a reason
um but you have kind of you know so the
answer is this inherently you're asking
what how will it help people the only
thing this does is information it
doesn't have any additional thing other
than providing information that may then
future help people to take action right
right go ahead thank you one more
representative Reed so in in that vein
the public information
acquired from the registry of deeds when
the property is sold lists the price
because you can figure it out from the
tax stamps it doesn't list a specific
price
so that's how the assessor figures it
out
so would you consider this an invasion
of the privacy of the landlord to make
them tell what they're charging for rent
each year no because like I said a
housing being the most important and
most expensive cost almost everyone has
B no other product is like that why is
housing the only secretive product if I
wanted to buy a dozen eggs we all know
how much that dozen eggs is if I want to
buy gas I know exactly how much these
prices are emblazoned so why is it that
rent the most important cost is the only
secretive thing that we have that we can
buy as consumers thank you for your
answer representative thank you Mr chair
representative majority thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
taking another question
um do you foresee that the community
that a community should also have to
send in or register with the or send in
what their increase their maximum
increase should be to the registry of D
so there's some type of reconciliation
I guess I didn't quite follow are you
saying when they increase the rent that
at that time they need to file that as
well that's because I thought that's
what was in my bill
that it's a yearly and when they
increase rent
did that answer I don't know ma'am Mr
chair what you may thank you I I only
foresee for instances if if my town were
to say the maximum increase is three
percent and the landlord sends into the
registry two percent should there be
some reconciliation that the landlord is
actually uh is actually doing better
than what the standards allow oh you're
talking about if the previous Bill were
to also pass in conjunction with this
I'm sorry I was I was completely within
this one bill
um so I mean yeah you should always
reward good behavior and so this data
could in to your example could be used
to highlight landlords that use good
practices as much as it could be used to
expose bad practices
representative L Word
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Reed
I'm looking at
um
uh RSA 540 colon 1-A definitions under
actions against tenants and there's all
types of different types of properties
some are excluded from uh some are
non-restricted properties restricted
properties
whether or not the term tenant or
tenancy shall include occupancy it goes
on and on
and so I guess I'm wondering
how this can be a public concern and
like unless each and every type of
tenancy can be recorded in association
with a
an amount of rent you know vacation
homes versus or vacation property versus
uh
and and so can you clarify how it is
that this property owned here is being
rented for a vacation property for three
thousand dollars a week
and the annual rents for however long
okay so how is that supposed to be
helpful to the public
so I mean it's a completely valid piece
of information that if you live on
Hampton Beach for example and it's
summer or rather if you own property on
Hampton Beach and it's summer then
that's going to go for more but that's
you know kind of across the board if
you're asking can counties include
certain areas as fake or certain areas
or even certain time periods or certain
qualifications like is this a short-term
rental for example as data that they
collect to kind of weigh that
information that they're collecting
that's perfectly valid again I'm not
restricting any of the data they collect
thank you represent representative
Cahill
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
do you think that employers could use
this data point as a way to say limit
raises if they know how much their
employees are are renting they know they
know the bottom line of what they can
afford and what they can't afford
um
I mean sure but or is the question are
they going to pay less than they're
currently paying because they already
use every uh rationale to pay as little
as they possibly can so on the converse
can then the employees go to the
employer and goes hey these are the
rental amounts in this area I cannot
live here and work for you for anything
less than x so that also is the other
side of that coin that arms tenants
foreign
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um you talked about how there is not
currently like
um
a lot of price fixing uh
going on with rents
but
um wouldn't the
um ability to be able to go onto the um
go to the registry of deeds and get all
of the prices for the entire
city region whatever and and
decide based on that information that
they couldn't get right readily right
now increase the likelihood of them
being
um
using that information to increase rent
so thank you for the opportunity to
clarify what I said earlier
um what I said or at least intended to
say was there's not to my knowledge a
lot of true price fixing but what is
happening is in effect price fixing
already in that this transparency is
what will help ameliorate it because
right now and so the idea that so if you
want you want to talk about true price
fixing that's where two people or more
go behind closed doors and say we're not
going to compete with each other I'm
going to keep my prices up if you keep
your prices up and that way nobody's got
an option
nothing that we're currently doing is
preventing those people from already
doing that and nothing in this bill
encourages them to do that so true price
fixing is unaffected by this bill the in
effect price fixing that is a huge
problem because I don't know if true
price fixing is a problem in terms of
like the actual illicit agreements
between people but the in effect where
we can just I'm just going to blame
Market but I'm actually going to raise
it 200 more than what Market really
demands but I'm going to blame market
and then the next guy raises another 200
over that and it goes on and on and on
that does get fixed by this and that is
probably far worse a problem it
certainly is a real problem that we can
point to and I don't know that the true
price fixing is
uh representative Hicks a while ago you
raised your hand I forgot about you over
there sorry
thank you Mr chairman
um thank you for this clarifying
question
I apologize I apologize if I missed this
and I'm reading recording monthly rent
charge at each property within the
county does that mean unit
or just the property
so my intent and I think this says it is
is unit per unit
because that's what you rent on a
monthly basis you don't if you have like
six units in a property you don't rent
the entire property
thank you
representative Brown you had a question
thank you chairman uh quick question in
regard to my property taxes I have the
the ability to block people from viewing
what I pay for taxes on my home
following up from what one of the other
Representatives said would uh rent to be
able to block this from being viewed
publicly because they don't want people
to know what they're paying for right
you know that's a very interesting
question and I presume that the county
could use the same exact method that I
feel so weird the same exact it's I
promise it's not disrespect
representative the same exact method
that they currently have to get that
information from a runner as they do
from a homeowner to block certain
information thank you
representative to 11. thank you again Mr
chair and thanks again representative
Reed
um
are you I am not aware that
what you pay for taxes in a specific
town or community
is able to be blocked as the
representatives are you aware of that I
was not aware I just presumed it was a
my own ignorance
um but if if it is the case then it
should it can be extended I presume if
it's not the case then I wouldn't
recommend creating anything new
certainly this bill doesn't do that
thanks follow up Mr chair
sure I hear you
um as far as I know
you cannot block the public from finding
out what you pay for taxes in your
municipality at this point in time just
FYI representative 11 is that a question
no it's not a question Mr chair please
forgive me the edification is still
appreciated one other I'll repeat uh for
the for our committee members we are
here to get clarifications on what the
individual given testimony is spoken to
and we can make our comments when we
exec the bills
are there any further questions
seeing none I have a series of very very
quick ones for you it's a simple answers
please
um could you tell me how many landlords
there are in the state of New Hampshire
I do not have that number thank you
um when the rents are recorded
um how are you going to ensure their
accuracy and who will verify the
accuracy
I don't I did not provide a method of
doing that in the bill it's the honor
System sure and uh the last one several
references or answers to questions
talked about the county gets to choose
how they do this or what they collect
where's that in the language I don't
believe it is required to be in the
language because this is just mandating
that they do the bare minimum but on an
administrative level they can collect
they do frequently collect a whole bunch
of information okay thank you very much
any other questions seeing none thank
you for your testimony we're going to
Institute the three-minute rule again
because we are extremely behind
um
well let's see we have we have about
four or five we'll we'll make it four
and please if the if the points have
been made try to not repeat them let's
start with Kathy Stacy
um
Kathy Stacy
good afternoon my name is Kathy Stacy I
am the Rockingham County register of
deeds and the legislative chief of the
New Hampshire Association of counties
I'm testify I'm testifying excuse me
today in opposition to this bill
um primarily a lot of information I'm
listening to testimony I'm kind of
surprised at how much responsibility is
put over to the counties that really
doesn't belong with the counties this
bill
is requiring what what's termed a
registry of rents
which means my office would have to set
up a whole new system
to document this information because it
would have to be separate from the
current indexing system that we have in
there and and just rest assured the
information that we collect very
specific when we're talking about land
records I have the biggest installation
in the state of New Hampshire my records
date back to 1629.
um and everything's available online one
of the biggest things about this bill is
the cost and expense to the county and
this actually violates 28a it's an
unfunded mandate we would have to
implement and pay for new programming
software Hardware you know the
implementation of a whole setup to get
it onto the website if it's available to
on the web
um and and quite honestly
um it it just doesn't fit in with what
we do now I it needs to be I mean invite
anybody to come to the local registry of
deeds to see what we do and how we do it
and what's located there I don't think
it's as simple as people think it is and
I can say that because I've been the
registrar for the last 29 years
so you know basically the counties are
asking to to vote this in expedient to
legislate we don't see the need the
requirement of having
rental information out there
um number one but number two the the
biggest the biggest problem is the
violation of
uh
28-day
thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative uh Guthrie I believe you
have a hand up down there thank you
thank you Mr chairman and welcome
Kathy's always nice to see you thank you
and I I just wanted to say do you think
that you've in your testimony you've
indicated what the indeterminate
increase will be in your in your budget
because we don't get that information on
the bill and that's part of the problem
you have 10 counties that have different
vendors who you know that we use for our
systems
um and so it would it would differ from
place to place I would have to get a
quote from a vendor to find out exactly
because you're talking about uh you know
putting together source code and
programming and you know so that we
determine so that actually you determine
what is supposed to be captured it's not
up to the county to determine what's
supposed to be captured uh you know in
in in the this index okay and because
currently we do not index by property
address we never have and we never will
we utilize map and lot or subdivision
information things like that but
everything is under the owner's name
everything that we have in our office is
under owner's name only that's how you
research you cannot research any other
way
I do want to address
one of the comments with regards to
masking of information at the Town
assessing and it absolutely is done I am
a selectman in the town of Salem and you
can actually go to your town assessor
and you have to have obviously a reason
why but they will mask your your
information there
thank you Mr chairman thank you Kathy
for your testimony
thank you very much
there any other questions representative
pop
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question you you may have um
answered this but I was taking notes did
the prime sponsor contact you to discuss
the um this bill in in the mechanics of
If This Were to become law and thank you
thank you very much for coming thank you
for your testimony uh next up we have
uh Nick Herman uh Norman sorry
your ends look like H's oh yeah so I
have
one day
thank you for taking my testimony uh
again my name is Nick Norman
I'm an advocate for landlords in the
landlord community
the government Affairs chair for the
Department Association of New Hampshire
same introduction as I gave you last
time
we are against this bill and asked that
you voted in expedient to legislate
some of the points have already been
raised so I'll just go through Brush by
those quickly
we would think that this is against
antitrust law because
it would
unquestionably lead to the effect of
price fixing
don't you think as a landlord you'd love
to know what Joe is getting for the rent
here and the Joe's getting and Sally's
getting for the rent to the the
neighboring property
of course it's going to lead to
increase rents
because
that's just the way it will be fine I
mean it does it take much to to figure
that out
um this would be a substantial expense
to the counties
it would require the raising of real
estate taxes
putting further in pressure on
increasing the rents
we don't need the government to put
pressure on increasing rents we need the
government to look at creating more
housing
again like I said before if you're not
looking at creating more
housing increasing the supply you're
looking in the wrong place
we do think that this would be an
invasion of tenants financial
information and landlords Private
Financial information
the bill doesn't say what must be
reported is it the total rent or
individual unit rents
what about
certain tenants that have been residents
for 20 or longer years and they have a
really low rent do they really want that
known
and wouldn't there then be pressure to
get that tenant's rent increased
what would it do in terms of financing a
property with all this public
information
and qualifications on financing would a
bank then want to step in and force the
landlord to do something about those low
rents because we see your debt income
ratio is too low we think you should
increase those low rents
what about the fact that there's nothing
in the bill that says what kind of
property this would uncover
residential property commercial property
any rent
a school district renting from a town
Church rental properties
there's no restriction here
additionally
rents are very varied right some rents
include heat and hot water some include
heat some include only hot water some
include Water and Sewer some don't
what is the meaning of a piece of data
if you don't have all the rest of that
on a commercial lease it's really common
to have triple net leases where the
tenant the commercial tenant pays for
the property taxes or the insurance or
the water and sewer without that
information collected it's fairly
meaningless to look at just rent
so we just don't see any usefulness in
this and certainly it's a tremendous
amount of administration there's a
boatload of rentals in New Hampshire
we're not talking about something small
there's a lot of rentals in New
Hampshire especially if you're now
including all commercial school
districts
vacant land anything that's rent so I
would encourage you to ask questions and
and I would ask you to vote in expedient
to legislate my contact info is on here
again please switch out to me
thanks for your testimony
I see no questions appreciate it
next we have Jessica margison
hello and now I get to say good
afternoon
um again Jessica marjison with Granite
State organizing project I'm here on
myself though
um but it shows my background as a
tenant organizer for 15 years the tenant
association and working on the
Manchester housing commission this bill
would be so hugely helpful to me as I
accidentally spoke up during the last
bill
um
in our meetings I have asked what do we
have for stock I cannot look at my town
stock of rentals available and see where
our shortages lie I cannot see that
when there's an ad for an apartment that
price is listed online there's no
secrecy of it there's no privacy needed
and I like to think about employees
employees are allowed to talk about our
hourly pay and why is that that is so
that the employee next to us is treated
the same as we are that is so there's
transparency and we're able to ask for
the same as the other employee has this
would give something similar to that if
they're allowed to charge us in our
state I don't understand why it could
not be added to a registry and I wanted
to mention 540
uh colon 1-b that is registry of D um
let me pull that up real quick so I can
pronounce it correctly
that State statue is um
541b effective January 1st owners of
restricted property must file a
statement with the town or city clerk of
the municipality in which the property
is located that provides the name
address telephone number of a person
within the state who is authorized to
accept service or process legal
proceedings this would be a perfect
State Statute to add that under
it also speaks on restricted property
the properties mentioned like shared
living situations or rental property
that falls under 540b normally as far as
I'm aware of not 540A which this statute
we could add this to
um we are face um so Manchester someone
did ask that question we put together a
quick reference housing guide in our
city that we're just now releasing and
so someone asked how many rental units
there were in Manchester
um there's roughly around 52 000.
um
right now the estimated number of units
the number of units approved in progress
1439 number of approved units offered
below fair market rate 210. I can't find
the number I need as I spoke about Noah
the naturally occurring affordable
housing that has been decimated across
many towns
with predatory landlords there's a a
thing they like to go after class C type
buildings these are dilapidated type
buildings these properties normally rent
for Less allowing someone who has not
been able to get a housing Choice
voucher to somehow survive until they
can get to that point these properties
are important because our state and our
federal government cannot produce enough
housing Choice vouchers to actually
house those on disability all of them
and those at below 30 Ami and when
you're talking about 30 Ami
um you're talking income for one
person's twenty one thousand that rent
looks like 525 a month I'm trying to
find the stock of those apartments
available for those people that I need
to fill that need and I can't find it
this would be hugely helpful and if we
can't show everybody this would be
helpful for commissions and those work
in the city our zoning boards our
planning boards when we need to go and
look at that to see what the need is for
offering incentives like 79e great tax
incentive for affordable housing
um
what is it um
okay you're gonna have to wrap it up yes
gun and questionnaire zoning hugely
helpful for that when incentives are on
the line
and I'll try and wrap it up there
because I don't want to make it take too
much longer thank you thank you are
there any questions
seeing none I have two very very quick
ones
um you mentioned employees can talk to
each other regarding pay is there
anything in the states uh like a pay
registry where employers have to report
their
what they're paying their employees no
I've never done um the closest I get to
employment advocacy is
advocating for the minimum wage to get
raised so we can afford our rent so
there's no pay registry no not that I
know of and again you said that they can
talk to each other regarding pay to know
how much they're each getting so they
can maybe get their raise can renters
talk to each other about what they're
paying they can and that's why we
shouldn't be worried about the privacy
of this and that's what I get told when
I asked our assessor's office can I get
a report of what rents we have in our
city to know what we're missing because
I'm always saying these units are
missing how can I show this this is some
way I can show this
maybe I wasn't clearing the question I'm
sorry that the question you made the
comment that
If the vice chair and I are
talking each to each other about what we
make so we can talk to our employees and
say hey we we might need more can't two
renters do the same without creating a
registry
they can but it that's not the main
focus of it one way it could help as
Norman stated when they have a good
renter they charge a lower amount but
when they have a bad renter they charge
a higher amount
um those are what they call a good
renter or a bad renter is up to their
definition but it would let that
neighbor know hey my neighbors pay in
half the amount because there is a state
statute along those lines like if you if
your landlord tries to evict you out of
your apartment because he wants to move
in there they're going to look at does
he have any other available units that
are comparable
if your rent was increased to this much
or the other comparable units the same
those things are looked at
thank you any other questions
see none thank you very much next we
have David uh Klein
thank you Mr chairman
I will do my best to stay within the
four minutes my name is David Klein I'm
a small landlord I have 40 units and
spread out between Dover Rochester and
Somersworth I am opposed to HP 422 for a
number of reasons first of all I believe
and I contend that the New Hampshire
right to privacy as state in article 2B
of the first part of the New Hampshire
Constitution makes this bill
unconstitutional unconstitutional it
states that an individual has a right to
live free from government intrusion in
private or personal information is
natural is essential and inherent my
gross rental information I think is
where I don't voluntarily disclose it uh
definitely personal com information
and I also think that major developers
I'm talking about shopping center
developers big office building
developers because they're caught by the
language of the spill it doesn't say
residential it says all renters also
that's confidential information to the
extent they make people who might be
buying or whatever sign non-com
non-disclosure agreements
um second of all this bill has the
potential hurting tenants and Nick
Norman touched on it very quickly I have
a tenant that I've had 10 10 to 12 years
now she's on Social Security walks with
a cane has no source of income well
except for the Social Security I'm
charging her 950 a month we've been very
light in their increases that apartment
can go probably for 1400 a month if
every tenant in the building knows it
I'm under charging her they're going to
be on my case about why aren't you under
charging me and you're exposing her to
harassment from the other tenants never
mind what's going to come our way is the
landlord
matter of fact I have to push up a rent
and what's going to happen if a children
don't who are helping her don't pay it
she's going to have to move
and that's not what we're all about we
want to be able to have that flexibility
and part of the problems with this this
bill is it can't build a database that
really reflects the differences in the
apartments
I have the building that that this 950 a
month tenant lives in the second floor
Apartments do not have washer dryer
hookups even though the foil plan is
almost the same
we charge less for those you're walking
up a flight of stairs you don't have the
washer drying hookups we pay for heat
and hot water there's a big reason why
they're less money I can't put that in a
database or that's going to be a hell of
a problem for someone like Kathy Stacy
and I also agree with her that this
building is an unfunded minute mandate
and completely goes against article 28a
at the first part of our constitution
also this bill should be defeated here
it's unconstitutional it's not going to
produce any Real Results that that the
advocacy of the bill are producing it's
just going to cause more confusion and
more problem for long-term good tenants
who have been undercharged because of
Lynn was like me who will hold down the
rent for the existing tenants who have
been very good and are long term
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak against this bill
thank you for your testimony
representative Gallagher
um so
about the uh point about privacy
um
so presumably it's already the case that
the person who is paying the rent
already knows that figure too right so
how can it be private information if the
person who's paying it already knows it
it is private they're not they're not
obligated to disclose it to anyone
just as much as it you know I mean I
would say this 950 tenant doesn't tell
anyone because she doesn't want the
other tennis knowing that she's paying a
whole lot less you put it in a registry
you're making it absolutely public
and let me say another one is
I would say that a company like Shaw's
they're not going to want what they're
paying per square foot or for a
commercial space public either
representative yokella
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
if someone has
um uh let's say live-in partner or
something that is as a personal
agreement to that they will be
contributing a certain number of amount
per rent or if they try to do a sublet
or something like that would though
um to you know a friend for you know a
month or whatever to stay in one of
their rooms in their apartment or
whatever like they have a two-bedroom
apartment or something
would that
um
now make the renter have to disclose
that
um
in your understanding of this and and
maybe you know a live-in partner would
also now that wouldn't be known to
anyone what the the
um like the contractual agreement
between you know a really person having
a relationship would now fall under this
um requirement to notify the registry of
deeds are you seeing that that might be
a invasion of the privacy of those
people the answer is yes to your second
question I think it is an innovation of
privacy second of all if you look at the
language of the bill is very broad all
renters
about people who lease have to report so
if the subleasing technically I would
say yes they fall under it that's a
practical matter who's going to know
about or who's going to trace it
thank you very much for your testimony
so you know more questions next we have
Mr Willett again
thank you Mr chairman for recognizing my
name
um I'm still gonna let's deliver one top
Auburn Street in Manchester New
Hampshire
you know we can't have it both ways I
suspect this bill will come back again
until it's something comes fast I I
regret that it does not say residential
because I I would think that that's what
they meant that's where the problem is
right now uh let me tell you an example
ten years ago in Manchester it was not
illegal
for you to have a one or a two bedroom
apartment and have three families living
in there because people couldn't afford
to pay the rent
but it became a fire hazard
like a hall you could only put in so
many people
and so the laws got changed for the
safety of the people
this is the same thing
do you know how many couches are being
used
for people who don't have rent
and most of your leases at least my
lease says that if I have a visitor they
could only spend 45 days at a time there
then they have to leave
and that's a federal rent so if it's on
the federal docket it should be on the
state as well or the county or the city
the problem is if you don't build more
housing and all you or all you build are
expensive housing not affordable housing
you're going to have more problems in
the state the county and the towns
because someone has to pay for the
people who can't afford those rents
they're outside
they're creating a not only a nuisance
but they're trying to survive they're in
creating more drugs more mental anguish
and it's the cities and towns that have
to pay for that extra cost
to maintain safety and people are dying
and it's cold so we have to do something
about the problems now and if we don't
start somewhere I'm hoping that maybe
this amendment there can be an amendment
made to this bill or normally at the end
of the sessions I know that the house in
Senate Conjuring
and decide what can be added or taken
away this is important it's a life
matter
it's a life man when you have people
dying in the streets
you have so many families that live in
cars do you know that in New Hampshire
if you're over six years old
you cannot have a daughter and a son in
the same room
but if you only have one bedroom what do
you do
so let's be careful let's talk about the
problems that exist and why these bills
are coming up somehow to resolve the
problems if they can't do it now you'll
have to do it down the road don't try to
do more harm than good thank you any
questions
seeing no questions we will thank you
for your testimony and call our last
witness if anybody else there out there
has intended to speak make sure we have
a pink card uh Kathy Holmes
thank you Kathy Holmes against this bill
I'm tempted to say I don't need to say
anything because I believe you all are
the majority vast majority smart enough
to know this bill is dead but just
um I I go ahead and say that it seems
benign collecting information
but it leads to further steps of
controls and these costs I think Stacy
that the uh Register of Deeds person
kind of put the nail in the coffin on
this uh has so many holes uh so and the
term predatory landlord has been thrown
out so much I really need to defend that
let's let's throw out the term deadbeats
there are they landlords have to deal
with deadbeats uh
for my husband and I our cars are and 94
a 2005 and our tenants always have newer
cars than us it's choices that they make
and every January we don't get the rent
because their kids had to have a blowout
Christmas in December it's choices
so uh thank you you have any questions
thank you for your testimony I see no
more pink cards so we'll close the
hearing on hb98
uh going back for the blue sheets
on hb95
what's that
no I understand I'm going back because I
didn't do it on the first one uh HP 95
um
we had 11 people sign in five were Pro
and six were against
on 422
we had one two three four
seven individuals sign up two were Pro
free work on and two did not
put Pro or Con on the sheet to register
their opinion
so there you go one more quick question
Mr chair
um yeah on online sign up there's also
online uh
opposer support so very good yeah thank
you if we can consolidate okay
um just for planning purposes we're
going to try uh we are way behind
normally we would break at 12 30 to 1 30
for lunch we're going to continue right
now I promise we will break to give
everybody at least a few minutes to grab
something to eat so we're gonna go right
into our next uh
bill which is House Bill 98fn relative
to applications for the low and moderate
income homeowners property tax relief
program and I rep representative
Melbourne
thank you Mr chair and committee members
my name is Charles Melvin senior I'm a
representative and I'm proposing
legislation to amend RSA 198 send me
colon 57 6 to change May 1st to February
1st this change would allow the
homeowners to file for low and moderate
income homeowners property tax relief at
the same time that they prepare their
federal income tax returns I believe
that the state can accommodate this
change because the relief is based on
part of the most current local
Equalization ratio as determined by the
Department of Revenue Administration and
by the education tax rate as shown on
the tax bill these numbers should be
available before the final tax bills in
December this change would make it much
easier for eligible homeowners to apply
homeowners who have their federal income
tax prepared for them they could have
the preparer prepare the
dp-8 forms the application is eight
pages and can be in intimidated to
people who are not used to filling out
government forms many eligible
homeowners probably need some assistance
in preparing this form currently the
forms are not available until the filing
deadline from the federal income tax I
became aware of this from one of my
constituents and am I uh
this program offers free income tax
preparation for the elderly and low and
moderate income taxpayers this change
would make it easier for lower moderate
income holders to get some relief that
is greatly needed
I expect this change would result in
more eligible homeowners applying for
this relief I've a cop I have a copy of
the RSA and the tax forms the eight
pages
and
if it's okay with the committee I would
uh one of our members I mean I have a
person here an expert on this tax
preparation and I'd like to defer any
questions to him if I could yes
Roger Hamill
uh we need to make sure to see if
there's any questions for you as the
presenter are there any questions for
the present
uh representative tetra
oh you were raising it for Guthrie okay
representative Guthrie
close enough Mr chairman thank you
and thank you representative Matt Melvin
for showing up uh in this league day I
just have a quick question is does Fear
to say that this question is just a Do
no harm question pretty much that it
pretty much just makes yeah it makes it
easier for a process to come complex to
begin with correct all right thank you
thank you Mr chairman representative
yokella thank you thank you for taking
the question
um
who whom did you consult with other than
your expert
um
as far as the the ramifications of this
uh uh date change did you talk to dra
and I did not talk to the dra okay
thank you but I understand that it could
cost more
because more people may apply for it but
I suspect that when the state initiated
this uh RSA they should have had the
money to pay for it
are there any other questions I have one
question for you and it may be better
for Mr Hamel but uh on the third page of
the bill under the mythology the
department note there
talks about equalizing the value of
properties by May 1st annually it may
not be they may about not be able to
calculate the property tax relief on
February 1st
how do you
get around that I to be honest with you
I can't answer that I think Roger could
Mr Hamel could answer that better for
you
thank you for your testimony uh
representative Manchester thank you Mr
chair you brought out a good uh Point Mr
chair the question is
do you know that uh tax
or the budget is set at the county level
which also has a part of the state I
mean property tax uh set at the
municipal county level so that doesn't
happen until May or June so to
preemptively do something at February
1st May jeopardize
the outcome
I I would agree with you and to be
honest with you I think that this
wouldn't be initiated until
the next year and then things could
change at that particular time
okay seeing no other questions thank you
for your testimony call Roger Hamel
foreign
thank you very much for having me I'm
here to speak in favor of
hb98 and many of my comments are going
to reflect what just what uh
representative Melvin just said but
I I'm Roger Hamill I live at 17 Spruce
Lane in Newton New Hampshire
I I I'm a volunteer in a program that
provides free income tax preparation
Services primarily targeted to the
elderly and low to moderate income
residents but I'm not here as support
part of that program I'm just here as
myself
the proposed change to the RSA 198
57 6A would allow homeowners to file
their low to moderate income homeowner
property tax relief at the same time
that they prepare their federal income
tax return
this change would make it easier for
eligible homeowners to apply homeowners
who have their federal income tax
prepared and then could have the the
preparer prepare also prepare the low to
moderate home property tax relief form
the dp8 at the same time
ep8 is an eight page
form that can be very
intimidating to people who are not used
to filing government Farms
many eligible homeowners probably need
some assistance in preparing this form
currently the form is not available
until after the filing deadline for the
federal income tax
this change could make it easier for low
and moderate income homeowners to get
some relief that is greatly needed
the Department of Revenue and
administration noted in a comment about
the proposed legislation that RSA 21j
313 requires Equalization
of valuations of property for each
municipality by May 1st and therefore
the equalization ratio
necessary for the property tax owners to
calculate their property tax relief may
not be available
by the February for us to filing I
believe that the Department of Revenue
Administration can accommodate this
earlier filing date because the
calculation of the
Equalization ratio
I believe that they can have it well
before May 1st they must calculate the
equalization ratio to determine the
State education portion of the tax rate
that is assessed on all New Hampshire
property owners that taxes assessed and
collected by the local municipalities
those numbers are typically available
for the final Town tax bill issued in
late November or early December
the proposed legislation does not change
the eligibility requirements but the
amount of the amount of relief it only
makes the application process less
burdensome
I hope that this change would result in
more eligible homeowners applying
for in receiving the relief that they
deserve under the current law
um and welcome to try to answer any
questions that you have thank you for
your testimony are there any questions
representative
thank you for taking the question
um so
you're asking that the department
um
uh produce a form that they produce
yearly a little bit earlier than they
normally do and the methodology the um
the department uh says that currently
they're required to complete uh
that process by May 1st are would you be
advocating for us to change that
requirement that they complete the the
equalization evaluation of properties
um by the by the uh before this deadline
that that would be one very good way of
uh to do that yes because I believe that
they they have the data they need to do
it but before February 1st and if you if
you wanted to require that they have
that done by February 1st that would
that would achieve the the objective
Representatives Davis
Sharon thank you for
[Music]
thank you for remind the May 1st
deadline I mean why was that set up that
way in the first time I have no idea
representative
thank you again Mr chair and thanks for
coming to testify before us I'm
wondering
um I'm reading the bill
um jumping off on what representative
yokella asked is Is it feasible that
someone could put an application in
on February 1st as this proposes yet not
here their
outcome until after May 1st when all the
tax
info is available from the town and the
county that would also satisfy what my
objective is my the but my objective is
that they they file it not that they
necessarily get the money back early so
so perhaps that that is another thing
that the you bring the filing deadline
so that they they have their income
information that they can put on the dt8
they can do the the property ownership
questions that are on a dp8 submit all
of that in yes and perhaps the
Department of Revenue doesn't actually
process it until May 1st that would be
fine that that would still do what what
I what I think what I'm trying to
achieve here thank you Mr Hamel
there any further questions
representative yakella
thank you
um it seems like
um you one one solution would be just
have a a Perpetual form and not have one
that come out each year but it seems
like the the reason that it comes out
each year is that the eligibility
changes and so you wouldn't necessarily
know whether you would be eligible into
until the new formula comes out well the
the reason why they have to have a new
form each year is because it's based
upon the equalization ratio which which
changes every year so the the income
requirements for the person to get a get
the relief doesn't change but the amount
of the relief does change and the um
because it's based upon the the State
education tax
no more questions I have one brief one
for you
um it appears you're the
individual behind this bill did you
contact the department of rev Revenue
Administration no I did not like I said
I I I'm just uh individual and didn't
didn't really know
the process that was needed
I I went to representative Melville with
this idea and asked him to to bring it
forward thank you any more questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
uh last pink card I have is uh Kate West
who appears to may be have gone
seeing no Kate West what's that
no no said individual
okay I will close the hearing on HB
was at uh 98 FN
uh blue sheet we had four people sign up
four in favor
okay
um representative
[Music]
fellows
how long do you believe it will take you
to present
s
it's actually it's that hand out for the
lessons with the last issue
would it be possible if you hung around
for a while we have not taken our break
you can't thank you we'll we'll take you
up as soon as we come back we'll ask
everybody come back at 1 30. we have a
couple things we must get done
shortly so we will see you at 1 30.
okay welcome back everybody
everybody else set we will open up the
hearing on House Bill 99 FN
representative fellows
oops thank you and um good afternoon to
the committee
um this bill does two things it changes
the name of this program from property
tax relief to property tax rebate the
reason that I'm doing this is because I
think people understand a re that a
rebate means that you get money back and
relief doesn't have such a specific
meaning the second reason for chaining
changing the title is that this past
year I heard representatives from both
parties refer to bills that were
property tax relief and so I think
changing this to just say rebate would
remove confusion with with just the the
general
um
phrase that people are using so that's
the first thing it does the second thing
it does is it um addresses the issue of
people finding out about this program
um the what has happened is the rebates
the eligibility caps to get a rebate
under this program were increased last
year so many more people are eligible
and I don't have any data to support it
but my belief is that it's primarily
seniors that are benefiting from this
program because I think that in many
cases people bought a house many decades
ago and they could pay the property
taxes when they were still working but
now that they're seniors and living on
fixed incomes that it they're struggling
to do that so I think this there's a
potential to help those people
when I brought this bill forward two
years ago I had done some research using
census data so at that time we didn't
have the 20 20 Census Data yet but I
think that at that time it would have
been correct to say that about one in
six homeowners would be eligible for
this program but since then we've had
covid we've had increases in wages we've
had increases in house prices but that
wouldn't you know that wouldn't um
really affect this program
so what I saw after the first year of
the program last year was the first year
with the new limits is that after eight
year eight straight years of the
enrollment in this program declining
which is something that you can see on
the on the graph that I passed around it
has turned around but it's disappointing
that instead of decreasing four percent
it went up but only by four percent and
I think that that's just another
indication that people don't know about
the program and
um
so so that's why this bill asks the the
um towns municipalities to put
information about this bill on their
property tax
from the ask the municipalities to put
information about this program on their
property tax bills that they send out
they're currently required to put some
information on it this is just asking
them to put specifically those income
limits and tell them about the program
so
I think I think that that will help one
of the reasons I think that will help is
this past
spring
which is the first time this program
came into effect with the up with the
higher income limits one of the things I
did I went to a new town that's part of
my district and I went around and I put
I put up posters in the local grocery
store and in the library and I knocked
on a few more than a hundred doors and
those doors were only people that I
could tell from the registry of
properties were living in a home that
they owned
and what happened when I went back and
asked dra last month you know if they
could tell me specifically how many
people in Ashland had applied
two years ago and then applied in 2022
how many people participated you can see
on the graph that before not a single
person Ashland's a fairly low income
Community for sure there are many people
that will qualify for this program and
they simply just didn't know about it
and afterwards you know this so when I
when I made an effort to try to inform
people
18 people applied and so if it goes on
their tax bill and the taxpayers see
that I think that there'll be even more
people applying for this program
um
let's see
When I Was preparing this bill one of
the things I did is I went to dra and
asked them if they could move up the
application date
and the person that I spoke to is the
one who does those equalized tables that
is the thing that's that holds up the
application until May and she explained
to me that there there was no way to get
those that the data about the
equalization and the tax rates
um until
you know it until May so that's why the
application the application period
doesn't start until May and I didn't
pursue it beyond that but from the
testimony we heard on the last bill and
from the um informed analysis that some
committee members made here I think that
makes me think it's quite doable that
they might be able to do that also I
think that that one of the things that
could happen is they can have as some
people suggested a generic application
that's the same all the time and all
they're filling in is their income and
then sending that to dra and when dra
gets it and then they get the equalized
valuation then they can they can fill
that in but of course that would require
some probably investment in computer
application programs to do that
the fiscal note for this bill talks
about the cost to the municipality to to
send out an application if they request
it you know so you've got
you know xeroxing right now there's
right now there's eight pages but if
they could make that change and let
people apply earlier there would be
fewer pages on the application
the cost of mailing that and and just
copying the application I think that's a
pretty small cost
I know that the town clerk in in my town
goes out of her way to help people
you know all that in any way they can to
help them pay their property tax bills I
don't think they'd object to that and
while you can go to the dra website and
find the application you
you would to you would have to
um not only have a computer
you'd have to know where to go which
could be a little bit of a challenge but
you know if you know to go to dra you
would find it you have to go two
different places to get a description of
the program and also get the application
if it's there right now it's not even
there because it's not the filing period
but you'd also have to have you'd have
to print it so you'd need a printer and
you you also have to send them your um
copy of your tax bill so you need a
scanner so that's really a big challenge
I think for many of our seniors and I
think it's a small price to pay
to to help some people out with their
property taxes
let's see
so I think that's
I think that's all about all that I have
to to say
for that
do you
okay thank you for your testimony uh
representative lasalles
thank you for taking my question uh
I'm just uh interested in your
definition of the term rebate
to me the term rebate means you pay
something and then you get something
back
is that what you're saying here
um yes so there is one little things a
little bit different about that a rebate
like if you go to the store and you you
buy something you know especially if you
like energy saving Appliance you buy
that and then you send in your receipt
and you get 25 back so this is the same
kind of thing the only thing that's a
little bit different and they'd have to
read the long instructions to understand
is people who
um
have a property tax bill but haven't
been able to pay it actually can get
that money back
follow up Mr chairman
uh yes sir go ahead
I'm just interested in the
administrative
uh timeline
to apply this could you go through that
uh you know how would they pay their tax
bill okay
okay so so let's say you you're you're
eligible in terms of income for this
program
so you're going to get a tax bill from
the town and that you might get your tax
bill like in November that's common time
and on that is the one line that says
what how much of you're paying for that
Statewide education property tax it's
broken down on your bill
and
so right now
if you knew about the program you would
be waiting until May
to even see the application form because
they don't post the application form
with those tables until you get to May
1st so you have to remember how long
your
you know all that time that you're going
to do that and then you have two two
weeks two months to do it so you so you
fill it out you send in your application
dra is going to look at it if they have
any questions they can contact you
because there probably are problems
sometimes and then they will send you
they will send you it must be a check
this is disconnected from when you go to
your town clerk and pay your property
tax bill as long as you have a copy of
that bill it doesn't matter if you've
paid it or not because that's a
negotiation with the town this is with
the state
thank you very much that clarified it
exactly
representative cholevin
mm-hmm thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question I'm just wondering if
you can tell me the population of
Ashland New Hampshire
two thousand thank you more or less got
it
representative Elward
thank you Mr chairman thank you for uh
testifying today
I'm looking at line four of the proposed
amendment
that starts with the word relief
in conjunction with
line three all the types of tax relief
available from the human municipality
then the omitted language includes tax
exemption credit abatement or deferral
so under the definition legal definition
of relief that is a type of Assistance
or Aid given to those in need especially
Financial from the state
hmm
no so that word release the tax bill
what you're reading is
the the word relief is current language
yes
and
okay
so I'm looking at the legal definition
yes I wanted to know which definition
most in your opinion most fit the type
of
representative fellows hold on a sec
representative valward
just when you have another question
please bring that through the chair okay
thank you
so
may I follow up with the
yes so rebate
is a return or part of a payment serving
as a discount or reduction
so this is providing a discount or
reduction to taxpayers qualified
taxpayers
the the amendment to this statute deals
specifically well I mean except for the
part that you're you're talking about it
deals with a with the um rebate
that the state gives to the taxpayer and
that that's what I want to call rebate
in in line four
that's old language and it's saying that
the
the town clerk should when they send out
the tax bill
tell the tax property taxpayers about
all of the programs that could give them
some kind of assistance
so they're not usually those are tax
credits like veterans tax credit elderly
tax credit
and if it's my understanding is
if they're low income very low income
they have to on my tax bill it says if
they're very low income they have to
apply for to the Selectmen
which is some process that I don't
understand I don't know what that
process is but that's relief is kind of
like a general category and in terms of
naming this particular program this
program is low in moderate income rebate
of the State Property Tax Bill perfect
thank you
representative manager Puti thank you Mr
two thank you representative for taking
my question so if I'm understanding
correctly rebate the property tax for
that particular property is the same
it's not changing it's the discount or
the rebate on that property tax because
you're low income or so if the hand
changes the property goes to somebody
who's not a low income
then they don't get the rebate
automatically correct that's corrected
because what entitles them to the rebate
really doesn't have anything to do with
their property value it has to do with
their income they qualify because of
their income but they but the only
people that can get a tax rebate are
people who own a a piece of property and
I'm not going to go into the details
here about
my new variations but those are not
changing those exist just one quick
follow-ups
quickly yes okay so this is opposite to
what the previous bills had you know it
stays with the property
the rebate not with the property it
stays with the owner of that property at
that time
the rebates go to owners
of owners
who
the rebate goes to homeowners who meet
the income requirements
representative Powell thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question my question pertains to section
one of the bill
and
um could you please clarify for me it
says the tax bill shall contain a
statement is this a separate insert in
the envelope in which the bill comes or
is this information printed on the tax
bill
so can you tell me which line you're
looking at three
line three
well three four five the tax bill showed
Oh contain a statement so this statement
I think it says I think it says down
below the statement can either be on the
property tax bill or it can be in on a
separate piece of paper mine
happens to be printed on the back side
of my statement but
it you know I well I think it would be
great if the town wanted to put even
more details have a whole piece of paper
put even more details on this program
and their own programs and put those in
the in the envelope with the tax bill I
think that would be great but it doesn't
require them to do anything beyond what
it says here
foreign
thank you Mr chair I have just a quick
question uh you referenced the town
clerk in mailing the applications and as
requested not all towns uh Town clerks
deal with tax uh uh tax bills because
there are there are clerk collectors who
deal with taxes but that some just have
a town clerk who does just this State
registration so my questions I'm not
sure it may be because I'm not hearing I
can't hear you really well not all towns
have a town clerk that collects taxes or
processes taxes so I'm just wondering if
you can
if you'd be willing to straighten out
that language
where you reference Town clerks mailing
applications upon requests Town clerks
somewhere else
is that existing language what line are
you looking at I don't have the line but
I'm sorry is it okay if I ask for this
section
I keep saying clerks because in my town
the tax collector and the clerk are the
same thing but I know in some towns they
are not the same thing
but right I don't think I changed
I don't think I use the word clerk Oh Oh
you mean that line 19 on the first page
the new paragraph assessment information
so that I didn't I didn't make that up
that was already in statute I didn't
change yet okay
thank you for your testimony I see no
hands raise
we'll call an ex-witness who I do not
see in the room
uh representative schuette
moving on to the other pink card I have
for this uh Catherine heck
good afternoon
um chairman turcotte and members of the
committee my name is Catherine heck and
I represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and I am just here to
comment on parts of this bill we have no
position on the state or the
legislature's policy to provide this
rebate program to taxpayers this is
solely administered by the state it
deals with the Statewide education tax
and it has not nothing to do with
municipalities
um the reason why I'm testifying today
is because this bill does raise just a
few concerns for us as now the
municipalities will be in the middle of
a state administered program so we
really do appreciate wanting to make
sure the program is widely understood
and known to all New Hampshire residents
if they qualify for this program I think
it's extremely helpful for them so it's
not to deter
that visibility and the accessibility of
the program however as the bill is
written it does require perhaps
additional information on the property
tax bill so for those of you who read
your bill you know there's already a lot
of information so I'm just going to make
a very broad assumption that just say a
second page is needed to be printed
there will be a cost associated with
that with the average price of a copy on
a commercial lease being two cents a
copy and there's 643
000 homeowners
owner occupied properties and sometimes
tax bills are mailed out twice that
would be a cost of about ninety six
thousand dollars
Statewide just for the copying so I
understand that's not a major cost but
again we're just shifting one tax burden
from one place to another so that's just
one small consideration again using that
same data if one and six are estimated
to one in six homeowners are estimated
to qualify for this bill
um that would be
approximately 63 000 dollars in Stamps
sixteen thousand dollars in copies on
the town clerk side to issue the
application for seventy nine thousand
dollars so this is a small a small
mandate financially for municipalities
but that doesn't include anybody's time
to process the application and mail it
out but the larger concern that we have
aside from this relatively small dollars
um respectively would be that we did
hear testimony earlier that these forms
are eight pages long and they do take
time to fill out and when the
municipality becoming the intermediary
the concern is that they would then be
required in some way or expected to
deliver
assistance in completing those forms So
currently again it goes to the dra and
the dra administers this program so that
was just a concern that we would have on
how that would be handled in the
municipality and who would handle that
administrative piece so again it's just
just some concerns that we wanted to
bring to light with the legislation so I
can take any questions that you might
have
representative stavis
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question can you point out
where in the bill
this potential requested assistance is
thanks
that's what I'm saying there is no I
think it's an a potential unintended
consequence that if you go to your town
clerk to request something to be mailed
to them that you might come back to the
town and also ask for them to assist in
completing the documentation as a town
would be now the forward-facing people
um handing out the applications
follow up yeah just quickly to follow up
so so there is no language in the bill
as it's written now that
makes that concern of yours an actual
reality is hypothetical right based on
the prior Bill's testimony that people
need assistance filling out the eight
pages it's just a concern as I said not
a mandate
representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony you said that this bill has
nothing to do with municipalities and
you also use the word mandate how come
there was no comment that this is an
unfunded mandate they in your
Association or us Osos Association
excuse me I'm a selectman uh would be
opposed to this bill yeah so as I stated
that that is our opposition to some of
the language that it is indeed an
unfunded mandate which I apologize but I
thought might have been implied in my
testimony no it was clear to me thank
you thank you sir thank you Mr chairman
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um a rebate is coming back from the
state does the town have to accept that
money as unanticipated revenues or is it
paid directly from dra to the resident
my understanding is it's paid directly
to the resident okay thank you
representative Brown
I'm just looking for a clarification on
that last statement over there were you
I don't care who it's from uh but my
understanding is that this is an
existing man uh rebate that people
allowed to get we're just looking to
increase the dollar amount is that
correct
um well my understanding uh from the
previous testimony and the sponsor of
the bill that they are looking to
increase the amount of applicants who
are eligible who perhaps don't
understand that this program exists on
the state level to provide that relief
to them
so I think it would might naturally
increase but perhaps the sponsor would
like to speak more to her the intent
Mr chamber could I have the spawn to
speak to that
no uh we're going to continue on if
you've got a follow-up you can do that
well yes because it seems to me that
this is an existing program we're just
looking to increase the dollar amount
that these people around is that a
question
um so I guess my question is is this
just simply an increase to the dollar
amount that's available to people that
are homeowners as far as rebates
I think the bill does several things
um that being one of them potentially
sir but I also think it it puts the
municipality in as the intermediary as
it stated at the beginning of the bill
that the municipality
um on line four
explain be able to share on the tax bill
all types of tax relief available with
this being one that we don't currently
administer on a local level
okay thank you representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
it
is it possible to say this is you know
the state uh without the municipality
intervening or being an intermediary it
doesn't go to the taxpayers the
taxpayers don't pay to the state so they
pay the municipality and the cut is
taken so doesn't that make sense for the
municipality to be the intermediary
because they receive the taxes and they
send the cut to the state
and vice versa if the state is giving
rebate for the taxpayers it should be
the municipality doing it because they
already do that so their position to do
that instead of creating another loop so
this bill is structured in that uh
resident homeowner pays a hundred
percent of their tax bill over and if
they qualify they get a rebate directly
paid to them right so the municipality
is not we are collecting the taxes and
the state is then reimbursing the
eligible homeowner based on the
administration of the program so the
municipality really isn't involved in
that in that process in that way all we
do is send the regular tax bill and
collect the funds
to share just a clarification no we're
gonna move on unless you have a specific
question about something she testified
on
I am trying to understand
municipalities already doing that for
the state
municipalities where the taxpayer pays
the taxes representative manager Puti
she's shook her head as to know they are
not doing that and again we do not
debate with Thee thank you testifiers
are there any more questions
thank you Miss heck thank you for your
time
I have no more
pink cards on this bill
this
I do not
yep
representative post do you have a pink
card on this
uh
for hb99
no we're on hb99
hey
representative fellows we are way way
behind I'm sorry but we we need to
I think
we have to find
understood okay
um hb99 is now
closed
and I apologize to everybody who's got
bills we are significantly behind we're
going to try to
hopefully Quicken up here a little bit
move quicker
um
up now we're going to open up the
hearing on HP 154
HP 154 I show representative
rebolia as the prime
comments
foreign
members of the committee do does
everyone have a copy of the bill because
I know the copies came in late
but okay
I'll just get right into it I know
you're uh running late but um thank you
very much and I'm uh for the record
representative Juliet Harvey bully
representing Tilton and samberton
um and I'm here to introduce house bill
154.
um
and just note that last year this
committee passed a similar bill on the
consent calendar and I thank them for
that
um this bill here is even less
objectional in my objectionable in my
opinion uh because it doesn't change any
regulatory Powers but basically what
this is is you know the an act relative
to the adoption of or how Public Health
ordinances are adopted by municipalities
so uh last year's Bill
excuse me changed um and made a
definitive list of what kinds of uh
items Health officers could regulate
upon this avoids that uh
at any rate and uh basically it's very
simple it requires that they can they
can pass anything
um
but it has to be finally approved by a
majority of the legislative body at an
annual or special meeting
this for uh it doesn't change anything
it only seeks to allow the legislative
body of the town to deliberate and to
vote on the ordinance
this bill will provide for robust local
control by the communities about their
own town ordinances the legislative body
of a town
is the is its registered voters as
probably most of you know
um that is the rule-making body for a
town is different than cities those who
show up to vote at a town meeting are
the legislative body annual or special
meetings I mean
um so you know how many public hearings
are required to pass a public health
ordinance under this
RSA 147.10
public hearings and arguably no public
meetings either because the law as it's
written now
says that they may pass the regulations
which will take effect when approved by
the Selectmen
and then recorded and published
similar to signing an invoice perhaps
uh it's there's no requirement for them
to be discussed deliberated upon in a
public meeting
I find this woefully inadequate
um
I think we'd all agree the public
hearings are the bare minimum
for passing of ordinances and such they
can affect everyone in town
um so how many public hearings are
required to change the zoning ordinance
in a town
two two public hearings followed by a
vote by the legislative body on the
question was put on the ballot people
are deliberate on them
um and it's very common every year in my
town we
get our public hearings and we get to
vote on our zoning ordinance it's a
great thing
um so this RSA
uh only pertains to towns uh not cities
the cities in my understanding have a
board of health and a different process
Health officers are lay people in many
cases especially in small towns often
they do the job of they have two jobs in
the town for instance
and so many of them have no Health
Training other than the three hours that
they get from the state
Health officers are also employees and
uh you know so it's we don't have
employees making regulations
in fact I believe this ordinance has uh
led to some confusion in the past
uh during the pandemic
Portsmouth uh Health officer cited this
and enacted a uh Public Health ordinance
without
a vote of the select board which
I believe is improper but I'm not going
to go into that so is this ordinance
consistent with the division of Public
Health Services yes
the the manual states that Health
officers are to provide a supportive
role when addressing communicable
disease emergencies and emergency
planning are coordinated by the
Emergency Management director of a town
RSA 21-p colon Knight 39
towns are supposed to have Emergency
Management directors and they're
supposed to be a team of people
addressing emergencies one of the issues
about this bill that was raised is a
concern was well what what does towns do
in an emergency well
that's what especially that's why I put
in special meeting
so they can do it in an annual or
special meeting special meetings can be
called
as the town needs them it's uh no
different really than any other meeting
or calling it a an annual meeting so
given that there may be some sort of
emergency
they can call a special meeting
in short order
um so lastly this does not affect Public
Health orders uh I know people raise all
kinds of concerns you know molds
drinking water quarantining bed bugs and
rodents and all those sort of things
that Health officers deal with there are
rsas that deal with all of those in turn
elsewhere in the statute
this is just for all the sort of
catch-all
things that may not be addressed but
they to my understanding from what I
heard from nhma they're almost this is
almost never
people almost never use this RSA 147 to
adopt ordinances we really didn't see it
until the pandemic
um so you know that leads me to
some examples
um but I just wanted to add that adding
public hearings to this process of
drafting Town regulations ordinance
ordinances are is a smart idea
not only does it enfranchise our voters
in the process but it eliminates obvious
errors that often happen in plague towns
for decades there are loads of examples
and you guys are all tired and I respect
that but just a couple For Your
Entertainment
um I believe it was the town of Kingston
that passed a liquor ordinance that
prohibited liquor from being on public
streets or in any kind of public way
they didn't specify unopened bottles or
open bottles
so it appears that you cannot bring
liquor home
using streets
um it when I was in the tent when I was
on the planning board in Tilton we had a
coordinates that limited home-based
businesses to such an extent that people
working from home on their laptops were
not sure if they needed site plan review
uh because the ordinance said any any
business that's done from home needed
site plan review
so I wrote the uh ordinance along with
the rest of the planning board and we
had our two hearings
and we voted on it as a town we passed
it and now people don't uh have to
pretend that they're hiding uh their
cookie making business at home or doing
a little work from home
um so that's what I have for you I
would love to hear uh your opinions on
that
um thank you very much
thank you for your testimony you would
not like to hear our opinions you would
like to answer any questions that we may
have okay yes thank you thank you very
much representative yeah
thank you Mr chair not an opinion it's a
question
thank you for taking my question
do you see any contradiction between the
bill that you're
of proposing here and RSA 128 colon 5
which enumerates the duties of the Town
Health officer
do you have a copy of 128
um I have I don't have it I but I have
read it
um
I'm sorry follow-up Mr chair I I I think
that
this bill of passed might result in some
substantial confusion between the two so
I'm I'm asking if you
would consider looking more closely at
128 colon 5 to see if there are
contradictions if that's something you'd
consider
uh thank you representative Davis I've
seen that
um provision in the statute I'm very
familiar with it um I
I believe there is quite a bit of
confusion
um
in all of in in
several of our health officer statutes
um that I don't want to go into but for
instance
um Health officers are supposed to work
in conjunction with the select board and
that is mentioned elsewhere in the rsas
as well but it's not included here
there's quite a bit of cleanup I think
and and clarification that needs to be
done overall one thing I forgot to
mention is that if you read all of the
New Hampshire division of Public Health
Services Health officer manual
guidance all of it says that as far as
communicable disease goes Health
officers are supposed to in towns are
supposed to provide a supportive role
educational role to the town and report
back numbers of
communicable disease illnesses in the
town
Etc
it doesn't mention anything about uh
regulate you know
sort of taking up going out on their own
and and uh
tackling it without the benefit of the
Emergency Management director or the
select board Etc
representative Elwood
thank you Mr chairman
your testimony today
um I'm looking at the the title of the
section local adoption of Public Health
ordinances
and then I'm reading the first line line
two
the health officers of towns may make
regulations
I'm wondering if it shouldn't say
propose
ordinances
thank you very much
is that a question or I'm asking you if
it should read propose ordinances versus
make regulations representative Harvey
bully I'm going to step in on this one
for the for your edification when you
see language
that is not highlighted or crossed out
that is existing language
so we're here
not that that you're necessarily wrong
there's a lot of language in rsas that
have written tremendously poorly but we
are only speaking right now to the uh to
the proposed language change yes sir
okay
as it relates to the proposed language
correct
um ordinances are by the legislative
body so
I find it confusing that it says
regulations
we're not supposed to debate correct
only ask questions thank you sorry about
that any other questions
seeing none thank you representative uh
call Wayne Whitford
good afternoon Mr chairman member of the
committee my name is Wayne Whitford I'm
president of the New Hampshire Health
office Association I'm here to address
the with the committee and discuss Bill
uh which is a revision to RSA
147.1 which has been discussed as new
assistance and so forth uh
154 adds a sentence to 147.1 which
states Health Options that may make
regulations for the prevention of
nuisances and other public health
hazards which must be approved by the
voters of the town
under normal circumstances a health
officer as may have already been said is
part of the Board of Health which also
includes the select board and is a clerk
of the Board of Health which permits
them to make recommendations to the
select board
uh the uh Health officer does not make
the recommend does not make the
regulations or ordinances or and so
forth it's up to the select board
themselves what normally happens is a
health officer may see a need for public
health and bring it to the select board
which they work with continuously
throughout the year
uh the board debates this
in a normal public meeting if it's
determined that is necessary or it is
prudent to form an ordinance this is put
out to a public meeting which is noticed
properly and the public has input both
at the select board meeting where
they're attending and at the uh
scheduled public hearing uh generally
anybody is interested provocon of any
type of Regulation or ordinance will
attend that meeting make this statement
uh known and in normally once that
meeting is held the select board will
determine if an audience is necessary
we see that working very well right now
we do not see an extra step of bringing
it to the town meeting which may be up
to a year away from the time of that
actual proposal and it just adds time
and administrative work to the uh the
local communities so local Health
offices Association sees this as
unnecessary in duplication uh taking
additional time and cost for the
community and not necessary
representative Brown you have a question
thank you chairman for taking my
question I guess your testimony seems to
be in Conflict what was originally
introduced
you indicate that there's already a
process where the select board has to
approve these ordinances am I correct
that's correct okay and then you also
say that the select yeah the follow-up
question represents I'm sorry
I'll get this follow-up follow-up
question so the selectman and the
Emergency Management director
work in conjunction with the health
official
to determine this and then
they have review of that in public
hearing that's how it's re required now
I cannot be positive if it happens in
every town in the state I know in my
community and in most communities it
does happen don't we
representative yokella
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um it seems like the the
example that you were describing would
be a ordinance not made through this law
um
are you aware of any
um of this specific uh law and how it
would be implemented without
um going through the selectman uh uh
ordinance process but the actual health
of Health Public Health ordinances
a health officer would always work
through the select board it would always
go through this process it wouldn't be
any type of Regulation uh brought forth
in the community without input of the
slack board
follow-up representative
a new line of questioning
a new line of questioning not a yeah so
give give anyone I see no other
questioner so go ahead
thank you and thank you for taking the
question
um
in
in a town that uh that passed uh Health
ordinance
um
for example uh uh Atkinson that requires
tattoo artists to be medical doctors
um do you see that there is any benefit
of having the uh
that the public May view that as as over
Broad and overstepping their bounds and
may wish to be able to vote at a town
meeting to say this is inappropriate and
we're going to vote this proposed
regulation down
do you see there's any value in that
thank you and of course they can bring
that up as an article out of town
meeting that certainly uh they just need
to uh request a form get a number of
signatures and it goes on the town
meeting agenda so that certainly can be
done in most cases where the town uh
citizens of the Town come before the
select board questions are asked and
answered uh and often uh the board may
change their mind if they're a majority
of the townspeople who do not want a
particular ordinance uh is likely not to
pass
I see no more questions
thank you for your testimony and I have
no more pink cards
so uh I'm gonna close the hearing on uh
HP 154 just so everybody knows that
we're three in favor one against
representative Harvey bolia could you
just answer one question uh you you
mentioned a previous Bill last year that
passed on consent what was that bill
number
could you just confirm it and send it
send it to me please just so I
thank you
okay
okay all right we're gonna open up the
hearing now on HB 433
providing tax exemptions granted prior
to a home sale
representative
post I show as the main sponsor
no
um I'm sorry who are you I'm Don griska
and Lisa post representative post is on
her way in from another Community you
cannot introduce the bill we will need a
individual uh representative Harvey
bolia you were on this could you at
least come in and just introduce the
bill
yes you
you are listed as a co-sponsor
that's 4 30.
what's up
no she's good okay
thank you members of the committee
um I'm representative hey here's Lisa
and she can introduce her bill
good afternoon and um thank you for
uh letting me know I was in
the wrong build before
um
my name is Lisa post good afternoon to
the committee I know you're really busy
I'm going to try to make it fast
um I appreciate your time today I am
representative Lisa post I cover
Hillsboro District 42 which includes
Library Mount Vernon New Boston and I'm
very happy to be here to introduce house
bill
433. this bill provides that the tax
property tax exemptions granted prior to
a home sale shall not be applied to a
new homeowner this bill provides that
property tax credits and exemptions
expire on the date that a transfer of
the property is filed with the registry
of deeds the new owners shall be
responsible for the difference between
the regular tax rate on the property and
the amount billed to the person entitled
to the exemption for that portion of the
tax year attributable to the new
homeowner
the new homeowner must apply for a
property tax exemption if if they are
applicable HB 433 is a constituent bill
that Miss Don griska who is here today
she is the assistant to the select board
and the Town Administrator and she
brought this bill to me because we are
losing funding in our town our Revenue
rather in our town from the delay in
anyone finding out that the exemption
has gone to the new homeowner and so
this bill will put a mechanism in place
to help us recoup that Revenue
um
I asked that Don griska can come up and
testify she is the expert on this in our
town and she has the expertise to answer
your questions and um
I hope you'll allow her to come up
so you you wish not to take any
questions and have her oh I'm fine to
take any questions okay
I think we have a couple questions for
you representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question so
um unfortunately I do not have a copy
that has line numbers
but my question is
um
this bill the new section lists out
exemptions
and my question is is there a reason why
the exemption for the deaf in hearing
impaired under RSA
38-b is excluded from this list of
exemption tax credits or exemptions
so that might be for Dawn but my my
understanding would be that that
exemption goes with the person and not
the property
so there are some exemptions that go for
property that like um current use
but there are certain credits that stay
um like if a veteran moved into
purchased a house and moved into a house
that veteran would still be able to have
that exemption
follow up yes
um
would it be would you be willing to look
into the exemptions that are listed in
and and note that I would be and
additionally
um
could you please look at 28-a
and verify that as well because when I
did look that up that was repealed in
2003.
so this was done by
um uh OLS and I did not verify those so
I apologize
it's 38a
any other questions representative
[Music]
thank you once again Mr chair thanks for
testifying and taking my question I'm
wondering if you have an idea in regards
to the length of time it takes
for a municipality or town town or a
city to discern that the property has
been sold and the person receiving the
exemption has moved out of the property
uh that is one of the problems that we
are having not being able to identify
that
um and there is an RSA about this but it
doesn't make it clear how we move
forward in in removing
those exemptions that don't apply to
them
for the new homeowner follow-up Mr chair
I'm confused
how can
mentality no
OK that a property has been sold
representative Gilman has an exemption
for her person right and she sold me her
house I don't have an exemption for my
person right you as a municipality know
the house has been sold how can you not
know
so I don't handle that end of it at the
town but Dawn does and she is here to
answer those types of questions because
she is intimately involved in that and
she works with the assessor thank you in
our town thank you
um you might
you
you wanted just the mic's on so I
thought you were going to talk that's
okay did you have a question
representative
thank you thank you for taking the
question is your current understanding
that
um that
if the town doesn't notify in a
reasonable amount of time that
um the tax
um
Bill may not necessarily be adjusted or
be able to be adjusted and so therefore
if they issued a bill let's say on on on
June that if the person moved out at the
beginning uh late May or whatever then
the it should be adjusted and prorated
to be a different amount but there's no
real process to do that now and so
there's uh some potential loss Revenue
in there correct okay there is and and
and with that we are working with the
New Hampshire Municipal
um Catherine heck who was here before
she's working with us we know we need an
amendment on a couple of things so we
will be doing that
um okay thank you just wanted to let you
know that
representative save us
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
I'm looking at a line
five of the bill
which ends with the words shall expire
doesn't that isn't that kind of
determinative of everything we're
talking about here
if upon filing a real estate transfer
with the register of deeds property tax
credit or exemption shall expire yes
so for some reason they they it it has
been transferred at least into our town
um and I believe there are other towns
that are having this issue as well that
they are not finding they are not the
these exemptions are not being removed I
don't know whether that's the fault of
the assessor or or
I I am not sure why that is
um
follow up
is the appropriate place for
fixing that very local problem a state
RSA
or is it a hyper local problem being
experienced by a few towns and a few
counties here and there
I I don't know the answer to that
question
I can look into it thank you
representative
once again thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking my question
um isn't
doesn't any town in the state of New
Hampshire receive a deed from the
registry of deeds when a property is
transferred
again I would refer that to Dawn thank
you
representative
thank you Mr chair
um
basic question the rebate tax rebate tax
is the taxpayer it's attached to the
taxpayer yes the tax amount is attached
to the property so that when the
property is transferred automatically it
has to go isn't it that's the process
I'm sorry I didn't understand the
question
okay
representative 11 did you have another
question or no sir I'm sorry yeah no
problem
okay seeing no other uh questions thank
you for your testimony we'll call next
uh don griska thank you
thank you good afternoon thank you for
your time hopefully I can quickly
clarify
so the way the system is set up now if a
Property Transfers at a certain period
of time of year
property valuations are as of April 1st
if a property sells that has a credit or
an exemption at a certain time period
because it is a first half second half
an owner that purchases a property can
receive a tax bill for the second half
that still reflects the credit and
exemption that they did not apply for
because it is a reflective moment it's
uh the entire valuation as of April 1.
so if it sells
after that period but before
the second tax bill
you have a person who has not applied
for a veterans credit who has not
applied for a blind exemption for a deaf
exemption for an elderly exemption that
is receiving the benefit of that credit
because it's the taxation as of the
value of the house as of April 1st
what I am seeking to have changed is uh
some form uh we're still working out the
technical details some sort of a
municipal
um re-accounting so that second half tax
bill
is credited so that you know the new
owner who is not a veteran who is not
elderly who is not disabled
doesn't get a credit for which they
don't qualify
the way the system is now they
automatically get the credit or the
exemption regardless of whether or not
they have applied
foreign
for questions I assume thank you
representative yukela
thank you
um what is your understanding of when
the
um change would actually occur for the
person that is not eligible anymore
would the would it automatically be the
next year in on that uh April 1st
so the way it it's an interaction
between April 1st and then September
first was at the ms-1 so depending on
like
um the worst of it would be between say
something a property that sold between
September one the the deadline for the
ms-1 and the next tax bill
so then that person if they were to sell
their home in that period of time it
would not be reflected again until the
next cycle
because it's an estimated first half as
the first bill the final half is the
second bill
so by some sort of accrediting system
that second half would get wiped from
the taxation almost like
um like when you're paying the first
bill you're doing an estimated first
half the second bill is whatever the
remainder is it would almost be as if
there was a credit to it a debited
credit if that makes sense
so say someone has an exemption that is
a hundred dollars for the whole year
fifty dollars first half fifty dollar
second half it sells between the two
halves right now the second person the
new owner receives that fifty dollar
credit regardless of whether or not
they've applied whether or not they this
would be a system that says okay that
fifty dollars doesn't belong to that
fifty dollar credit doesn't belong to
that that person no longer owns that
property and it would be some sort of a
technical balancing of the books if you
would to take that 50 credit off the
books so that they receive just a
regular tax bill no credits no
exemptions if they don't qualify for
okay hello
once again thank you Mr chair and thanks
so much for coming in to testify before
us today
um my first question
because I may have another question but
my first question is when that second
tax bill is sent out
does it have the text bills I've seen
that have exemptions on them say
Mary Jones and Edward Jones and the tax
and they say veterans exemption right on
the bill
the numbers right there so if the bill
came to me
and I bought their house and I wasn't
Mary Jones and I wasn't Edward Jones
would I know by reading the bill that I
am not qualified for that exemption not
necessarily
um different tax software different
assessing software
present that data on the tax bill in
different ways so certain software
systems it is just baked into it in some
software systems it is called out
I understand follow-up Please Mr chair
go ahead thank you very much thanks for
taking another question
I'm assuming that a human being is
running the software the tax bills that
go out from most of our towns and cities
and that that person might even have a
change of address form on file and send
the tax bill to the new owner and I
understand about its estimated first and
it's real second if they're in that
window wouldn't you assume that they
would notice that there's an exemption
on that bill that doesn't belong to that
absolutely okay that's so the the
the
the gist of it is we recognize that it
it is being given to someone who is not
applied but the way the statute is
written now we are not allowed to just
make it go away at the time of transfer
we are required to leave it right where
it is it it pains assessing officials it
pains Town clerks tax collectors
many towns admittedly as I understand
probably just
do it anyways
the statute says and admittedly this
came up in a conversation with our dra
representative who said Thou shalt not
change it and we said that's not fair
that's not right and thank you thank you
thank you so much for the clarification
I've learned a bunch of things today
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony
if the sale takes place between the time
of the the end of the first half
and the end of the period period in
other words halfway between what what
adjustment is made then
and if any
do you understand a question I'm not too
clear of myself if I know what the
question was myself I'd be delighted to
answer if we give it one more go of the
question yeah so if the sale takes place
after the half year
but before the end of the year what kind
of an adjustment is made now not what
should be done but what no there is not
okay
the new owner just receives the Creditor
exemption that they did not apply for
so just for the edification of the board
if the chairman will allow me
I bought a house representative
a veterans exemption on it
and it was still on it when I at the end
when I got the second Bill and because
I'm a public servant I went back and
told the Town Clerk and made an
adjustment which you are trying to do
with this bill is that correct it this
is why that is why what you experienced
is what we were trying to fix thank you
thank you representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I certainly understand where where
you and officials would be concerned
about this
um do you know how can you tell me how
many complaints
from property owners who experience this
you have received none
none not not follow up mister
sure follow up
okay thanks no no the concern is
predominantly lost Revenue
representative lasalles
foreign
thank you for taking my question is it
your understanding or your knowledge
that this is occurring in all towns
throughout New Hampshire yes
thank you
representative majority thank you Mr
chair I should have kept going with that
too but when they receive so so my
question is when they receive that next
bill we've got a bump how do you explain
that to them and then is that perfectly
crystal clear to them which they in
which bump new people
suddenly now have a bump because the
exemption has expired
there is a bump on their tax bill why I
assume they asked that question of you
why and perhaps I misunderstood your no
I didn't I I I was trying to make it we
have never got a complaint saying hey
I've got a credit I really not you know
I want to give it back we have gotten
conversations and credits to say my
previous bill was this much less and now
there's this bump why and we have to
explain that that's the way the law is
written
thank you
Mr chairman I got a quick I got a
quickie if they could you have a quick
question yes a very quick question go
ahead representative Guthrie thank you
Mr chairman
what happens if somebody buys a home
has as a veteran say
the exemption is not on the second half
of the bill can he or she recover that
exemption
sorry I could ask one more time
person buys the house they they have a
legitimate they're a veteran but the
bill does not have a veterans exemption
it's the second half of the bill can
they can they recover that or get that
rebate so there is a deadline filing
period for filing for credits and
exemptions So in theory one of the
technical details we would look at aside
from making sure that the bill didn't
get added inappropriately I would almost
think it's just as fair to change the
deadline period to be more rolling so
that whenever you are a veteran and or
able disabled blind whatnot you apply to
the system and through this system
whatever time of year it was you could
receive the credit all right thank you
seeing no more questions thank you very
much for your testimony last
on the list Catherine heck an HMA
good afternoon Mr chairman once again
and committee members my name is
Catherine heck for the record I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and we support the concept
of this legislation and that people are
taxed and pay a tax bill that's fair and
appropriate and accurate and we are
working with the sponsor to fix what we
believe are some technical concerns
based on how we currently set our tax
rate there's approximately 25 forms
involved in setting the tax rate that
are filed throughout the course of the
year they're all one point in time forms
which is why this exists and we are
looking for the technical fix so that
this bill might be able to come forward
and be implemented properly so if you
have any questions please let me know we
do not have an amendment to offer yet at
this time
representative of your color
thank you
um you said that you're you're working
with the to come up with the solution
are you is it your belief that what is
the time frame of that is are you
thinking within this legislative cycle
or
thank you thank you for your question
that's a great question well I we think
it's important that all the stakeholders
be involved so the clerks the asset the
tax collectors rather the assessors and
sitting down to make sure that whatever
is proposed can be properly implemented
so when it comes before you for a
decision so we're not exactly sure on
that timeline but we're working on it as
diligently as we can because we
understand the time constraints
any other any other questions I see none
I have one uh a long representative of
the ocalas
question
do you see the logistics of the
implementation of this of being
fairly significant
I think it depends on the solution that
we can come up with
um so I I honestly don't have an answer
at this time
but I think there's a reason why the
statute is whether it is currently and
why this hasn't been able to be
addressed I do think that there's some
out of the box thinking that would have
to occur
the way we currently set the tax rate so
thank you for your testimony thank you
are there any other individuals wishing
to speak that was the last pink card we
have
seeing none will close the hearing on HB
okay we'll open up the hearing on HP
all right
HP 295
good afternoon
if anybody has pink cards please uh put
them over by the sign in sheets there
and then we can uh have them delivered
up here thank you
okay representative uh Damon you are up
thank you chairman turcotte and thank
you to the full committee for your time
and interest in hearing this bill
in my life before becoming very recently
a representative I'm a public health
dietitian diabetes educator I think you
all should take a stretch
long day eh
so for the record I am representative
hope Damon representing Sullivan
District 8 which is a new nine Town
floaterial it serves the communities of
Acworth Goshen Langdon lemster
Springfield Sunapee Washington my
hometown of Croydon and the City of
Claremont
a pretty diverse beautiful District
HB 295fn asks communities asked to
require communities to record and live
stream all public select board and
school board meetings it would create a
permanent record of these meetings and
most importantly provide the same
transparency and accountability that
YouTube of our house public hearings now
routinely makes available
while this does currently happen in some
communities throughout the state
including Claremont and Sunapee and my
own District It Is by no means Universal
making our local government process more
visible increases trust in the work of
our dedicated volunteer elected
officials it invites greater citizen
awareness and participation
it likely has future benefit by
increasing candidates for local
positions that's what's happened in
Croydon since we started doing this
especially in our small rural towns
where often seats are filled by the only
person running sometimes regardless of
their Fitness for office
perhaps it even creates greater
appreciation of the work of elected
officials
you understandably might ask why is this
needed as people can attend these public
meetings
yet some elderly folks find it very
difficult to get out and must be
selective about how often they ask
family or friends to assist them in
getting places we need to hear their
voices and benefit from their
accumulated experience
for parents of young children early
evening meetings are very inconvenient
Child Care is expensive and often just
simply not available again we need to
hear the voices of these citizens they
are the future of our democracy
people with physical limitations may
find it simply too complicated to
participate in person
in my own town a young man severely
injured by a motor vehicle accident has
benefited from meeting on Zoom it's
really great to hear his engagement
finally making meetings remotely
accessible is better for our Collective
Public Health as we learned during the
pandemic
for those who might question how many
citizens would actually watch I note
these points when I was initially
campaigning for State Rep in Claremont
where I was not well known I attended a
city council meeting and unintentionally
chose a seat that was on camera often
next day as I was door knocking multiple
people told me they had met me quote see
me or heard me the night before on Zoom
I decided to own that seat for future
meetings
just last evening the Croydon school
board was scheduling a budget hearing
discussion of which town building would
accommodate the expected audience
quickly was influenced by which site was
most feasible for Zoom as people have
come to expect and appreciate streaming
meetings
now the challenges
I acknowledge that technology isn't free
Broadband isn't yet universally
available and reliable however in most
communities this can be done for very
modest costs that is appropriate for the
values I have noted for example Cordon
doesn't currently have adequate
bandwidth to live stream from our town
hall if more than a few people are on
their devices
a local Warren article asked the town to
install starlink at a one-time Hardware
cost of 599 dollars with a reasonable
monthly fee of a hundred and ten dollars
appropriate camera and microphones are
increasingly affordable a setup overall
can be purchased for less than two
thousand dollars
or as basic as one board member sets up
a zoom on a laptop or YouTube not
perfect quality but available affordable
and as noted in my Croydon example from
last night appreciated by voters
there are also companies such as Town
Hall streaming who will contract to
provide this Service Hardware is free
with a monthly subscription fee that's
contingent on the number of meetings but
in the range of 100 to 200 monthly I
learned about town hall streaming from
the Sunapee Town manager who indicated
they are very pleased with the service
and I've spoken with the New Hampshire
proprietor I think they're a national
company or at least Regional and they're
very open to more business I don't
believe they're the only company that
does this but one that I can note
in closing if we value citizen
participation informed voters and a fair
Democratic process we will move forward
House Bill 295 to improve transparency
in local government thank you for
consideration of this bill
representative yokella
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um is your intention of not having any
penalties
um associated with this to be a strong
encouragement but not actually uh
uh mandate uh from the from the state to
the local municipalities to you know
spend the two thousand dollars right
this very moment
excellent question
I would really love to see this happen
in every Community however
I am respectful of the differences
throughout the state the differences in
size of communities
at least having it as a strong
encouragement gets the topic on the
table hopefully
representative Guthrie thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your hard work
that this must have taken and not only
that for the transparency that this
would result in
having said that
do you feel it's necessary to for the
state to legislate what should be being
done in communities and which each
Community should be able to make that
judgment based on their own financial
situation and I have a short follow-up
as the chairman if I could
thank you for your question
I wish that there was a universal point
of view throughout boards throughout the
state
where everyone agreed that transparency
in government is a good thing
quite frankly I don't think that's true
and we have experience locally and I
know of other situations not in my own
District
where board members were very
unwelcoming and resistant to being
recorded
never mind streamed or or made the uh
proceedings made available subsequently
never mind live so I do think that the
state needs to step in in my follow-up
Mr chairman if I made a very short one
yes representative uh would
what does communities do that have a
contract
with a cable
that requires them to use Comcast or
infinity or whatever and the people who
are
viewing only have
facilities for Comcast
a lot of us say there's some cowardly
board how would the boards work around
any contract limitations they might
already have
if I understand your correct question
correctly and if my answer sounds like I
don't will clarify me neither
um so if a community
is broadcasting through one company say
compass
and some of the citizens don't have
Comcast that's what you're yes asking
how they work around that
I don't know
um
I mean at a minimum they would be able
to view it subsequently if it's recorded
there would be a way to do that
um
if it's live streamed in many
communities it's going to be connected
to zoom and people can access Zoom from
whatever their provider is or a similar
platform to zoom go to meeting or
something
but that raises an important question I
just wanted to bring up their odd some
problems outside of
the fact that we were legislating the
towns and cities do this thank you
freely I'm sorry representative Brown
yes I just said thanks for taking my
question thank you Mr chairman uh the
question I have is why is it
significantly different to have it live
streamed as opposed to Simply recording
and posting it on like a town web page
which I know many towns in the state
currently do
thank you I may be making an assumption
here which is always risky
but I think when people see things live
they feel more engaged and involved than
when they're watching the recording and
therefore more likely to
stay connected to it
ideally it would in fact allow
participation that someone would at a
minimum be able to type a question into
the chat and there would be a probably
volunteer citizen reading the chat and
reading off the questions we've done
that with some of our school board
meetings very successfully I'm sure
we're not the only Community to do that
um
recording and having it available
subsequently is far better than not
recording
but I do think in real time is best
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you thank
you for taking my question
um I imagine like my town many other
towns probably have these meetings in
only one or two places maybe it's at the
school and the town and or maybe they're
in the same building
why are you only including select board
and school board and not planning budget
Heritage water I'm thinking of all the
commissions that we all serve on if it's
recorded in one place
so I think there's two-part answer to
that
not all communities is it in one place
um
but perhaps there's there's certainly
limits I mean a couple or three
to be honest when the bill was
originally discussed among constituents
and I there are constituents here who
will speak to it
the intent in fact was to require for
all
uh Community public organizations you
know governmental organizations
and we edited it to attempt to be more
successful at getting it started
I'd love to see planning and zoning
boards Etc be included
representative Holland
so I I see the I I assume what you're
saying is you want more transparency and
that's why you want the live streaming
and the recorded what happens if both
fail would you suggest that the meeting
be rescheduled or with the minutes for
the meeting be sufficient
thank you for your question I
anticipated that
um I think in the regulations for the
bill there actually should be a clause
that says in the event of
you know either a few specific like
Broadband failure or
not looking for excuses but
it loss of power yes thank you
um that it would just need to be noted
in the minutes of the meeting why it was
not recorded and streamed
um I mean human error happens too and
I'm not trying to make
penalties and make it so difficult for
people that we put hurdles in the way
I'm just trying to help people
participate in government more readily
thank you representative Damon for your
testimony
thank you for your attention
uh next we'll call nature Grace from the
HMA
thank you Mr chair Nate Grace from the
New Hampshire Municipal Association
we do oppose this bill
um in doing some Outreach when I saw
this bill on the calendar last week I
reached out to the town of Grafton and
the town of Easton one of the select
board members from Easton is here today
to testify in opposition so I won't
speak about them I don't believe anyone
from Grafton is here today unless I miss
them behind me
um there were practical concerns with
this bill regardless of the policy so in
the town of Grafton there's no internet
where they have the select board
meetings I've spoken with a
uh a representative since that time
um in in the legislature who
apparently has good cell service uh
where he lives but he is fortunate
um and so he has a combination of
starlink which he doesn't use for caucus
meetings
um or other important uh online meetings
because he has seen that it has an issue
with pausing with stuttering because of
course it uploads to satellites and back
down so he couldn't guarantee that he'd
not miss things or that people on the
other side would miss things
um and has to use uh because of where he
is in town he can actually use a Verizon
data pack but that's not available
throughout the town of Crafton
um and that's I think just one
illustration of a number of issues that
communities are going to face simply
because they don't currently have this
capability
um I know it's not before you today but
I know that many of you were involved in
discussions about remote meetings in
previous legislation and one of the
concerns that the legislature had was
the ability to actually
have those and have access to them
because that's the intent here is to try
to get access
Broadband is being built out across the
state there's a I don't remember exactly
how many year plan I think it's three or
four year plan it may be appropriate at
that time to
revisit the idea of how to encourage
this type of of
um
opening up government activity to
members of the public but at this time I
think that it's it's premature because
we simply don't have
Broadband stable internet Broadband
access at every town hall throughout the
state and that's really what we need and
I'm happy to answer any questions that
the community may have
thank you very testimony representative
stabis
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Graves for taking my question
um does nhma think that because some
towns lack specific infrastructure that
this bill might not this bill
um
facilitate the adoption of more such
technology and isn't it also true that
technology is getting so rapidly to the
point where just everyone everywhere has
access to it
why would nhma want to hold up a
potentially
positive development because a few towns
don't have internet access
it isn't one thing so we represent all
234 cities and towns and so we have to
be conscious the fact that some of our
members simply don't have the type of
infrastructure at this point in time we
have been working diligently to get more
funding for Broadband infrastructure
that's something we've been advocating
for for several years now we've
partnered with many of you on that that
is getting built out slowly
simply because there aren't enough
people to build it out
and we are hopeful that that will happen
in the next few years and we'll have
better access throughout the state it's
been something that has
um impaired our ability to grow our
economy and it is something that we are
very much aware that our members want
and we are advocating for so it's a
little premature to discuss it at this
time
representative Edward
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon Mr
Grace good afternoon can you tell me how
many of the 234 cities and towns are
without
infrastructure at this time
I don't know off the top of my head
um
I do know that it's mainly the more
rural communities in the North Country
meaning kawas county Grafton County
um and then I believe Belknap and um
to some extent
um
nearer the Seacoast but that's that's
pretty well served Stratford county is
what I mean Rockingham County is well
served Hillsborough County is well
served
much of
um Merrimack County as well served there
are some Pockets that don't have quite
the same but there are some like for
example the town of Bradford I call them
and they'd actually just seen a fiber
fiber Line run out there about three
months ago so they actually have very
high speed internet at the moment they
are broadcasting their select board
meetings and certainly we have been
encouraging members to do that because
we saw the increased participation you
heard the sponsor talk about quick
follow-up sir follow-up
can you tell me how many of your members
cities and towns have websites Town
websites
I believe most of them do okay
thank you representative Manchester
thanks
thank you Mr chair
uh thank you Mr Grace for taking my
question
if
only few handful of
uh
municipalities do not have access
don't you think it would be good to
implement something and they adopt it
because this is a good practice rather
than saying don't do it at all
I I would say that if the state would
like to pay to run a line out to the
town hall and Grafton and Easton and the
other places that are underserved we
certainly would encourage that we don't
currently have that ability I don't know
of any bill on the table that would
offer that I do know that towns are
working through the Broadband Grant
programs of which there are several we
are assisting them with that but we're
not
we haven't built out to the extent yet
where every town is served
a follow-up Mr chair just a quick uh
we'll come back representative
thank you thank you for taking the
question you seem to be focused mostly
on your testimony about the live
streaming portion
um if
that can you speak to just having a
requirement of the video of of of uh
video recordings and if uh live
streaming is not an option if if uh
video recording is something amenable
so I haven't previously considered that
I'd have to get back to you uh about it
um I
I guess just as a practical matter
we generally oppose things that would
impose new costs on municipalities and
so
um requiring them to purchase new
equipment they may not have and would
not be expected to have because they
don't have that type of Technology out
there or that technological service at
the moment
um
is possible as well
um the other thing that I would I guess
sorry the other thing I'd like to also
raise in that context is
the question of technological failure
and what exactly to do that wasn't
addressed in this bill I know that the
sponsor mentioned that she would be
interested in in looking at that as well
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and I I think this
and thank you for taking my question Mr
Graves I think this might be an add-on
to what you just said does this then
create an unfunded mandate and and then
create a violation of 28a I think that's
a distinct possibility yes thank you
representative manager put he had
another question uh thank you if this is
an opt-in
those that have the capability do it and
those that don't have are not going to
be penalized would that make it
a more move forward kind of uh
so I think we have to be careful when we
pull different policy levers and I think
if we were to have an opt-in that would
require additional costs you might see
places that don't have these
Technologies not want to opt in they
might not want to allocate that a town
meeting their voters might vote it down
um certainly we would like to encourage
municipalities and we certainly have a
policy position to
go towards open government and to
promote that so we would like to
encourage that kind of voluntary
um
voluntary work but we we don't want to
we don't want to do anything that might
upset the apple cart
foreign
thank you and thank you for for uh
taking the question
um if someone put uh a Warren article if
if this was enabling saying that if
someone put in a Warren article that
says that the uh townshall do this
um and appropriated some money to some
taxation money
um under the current law is your
understanding that the selectman could
choose to not actually purchase that in
for uh stuff
uh correct even though it was it was
passed by the town asking them to do so
right so if there was a petition worn
article that
um allocated money raised and
appropriated money for the purpose of
purchasing this equipment right and it
it passed
um that would authorize the select board
to do that they wouldn't necessarily be
required to do it much like the case
with you know a warrant article for a
new snow plow
um
they're supposed to safeguard the uh
Financial interests of the town and make
prudent decisions so they may not but
obviously everyone who works in local
politics know that if something passes
especially if it's with a big majority
that there's a large interest at the
local level of that happening so I'm
certain that they would work towards
trying to accomplish that goal
seeing no further questions I have one
brief one
um
based on a lot of the talk about opting
in and warrant articles and all this
is it my understanding that right now
there would be nothing that would
prevent a town from recording live
broadcasting live streaming if they so
so chose to do correct there's nothing
preventing them from doing any of this
at the moment thank you
okay uh next up we have uh Edward Spiker
um a lot of what I uh what I have to say
will Echo
what hope has said
um but if you'll give me two minutes
I'll wrap it up quick and you guys can
do what you do
um hello good afternoon my name is
Edward Spiker I'm a resident of Croydon
New Hampshire co-chair of stand up for
Croydon uh civil advocacy group that
promotes robust nonpartisan Civic
engagement and an active member of my
community first I'd like to thank you
all for having us here today and
allowing us a few moments to convey our
thoughts and opinions on House Bill
295--fm and others myself and many other
residents of this great state fully
support HB 295 FN for a Litany of
reasons a few of which I'd be happy to
shed some light on today House Bill 295
FN a bill which would require all all
public select board and school board
meetings to be recorded and broadcast
live online is not only a step in the
right direction it may be the only
opportunity for some residents to become
informed and feel as though their voice
is heard and that their opinions matter
uh coming from a town where a select
board does not provide remote access to
or record meetings to make available for
later viewing makes one appreciated so
much more when other boards care enough
to do so take for example those with
severe physical limitations who can't
make it to a meeting in person do their
thoughts and opinions on matters of the
public matter any less than the person
in the room
I'd like to think not
there's also a vast number of elderly
residents in the state that are unable
to make it to some meetings in person
due to time of day inclement weather or
for health related reasons this bill
would allow them to be involved and
remain informed about town happenings
that matter to them it also creates
opportunities for towns to benefit from
the knowledge and experience of our
senior citizens
as someone that has been unable to
attend meetings in the past I've seen
what can happen when people are
uninformed last March I took it upon
myself to begin recording and live
broadcasting all town and public all
public town and school meetings in
Croydon since no one else on the board
seemed to want to do that
I was unaware that I would receive such
an outcry of support from residents of
town just for making access possible I
was also unaware unaware of the amount
of voluntary work that I had signed on
for and how many meetings that I would
be regularly attending this bill would
serve to take the responsibility of
providing remote access off of the
shoulders of the public and put it on
the boards to offer transparency and
accountability to the people that they
represent for these reasons and more I
believe that the pros greatly outweigh
any cons that could arise and I implore
you to support and put forth into law HB
295 FN thank you for your time and
consideration and I'd happily take any
questions you have
representative yocella
thank you can you
um
kind of go into some some detail on your
thoughts about the value of of the
recorded
um entire uh meeting versus just a
summary of minutes that may not be as
detailed absolutely great question
um minutes are great but minutes are
usually provided by one of the board
members that are there and they can
include what the board members choose to
include a lot of times
a audio and video documentary
of what happens in that meeting
offers far more insight to what happened
during that meeting than
10 sentences on a piece of paper Ken
anytime
and the folks in Croydon
um
the folks in Croydon greatly appreciate
it the act just being able to access the
video
let alone being able to see it in real
time live as it's happening
it's it's really an invaluable service
thank you Mr chair thank you for
uh taking my question
um
in in your town you don't have any local
closer TV access or anything right
there's no closed circuit TV uh the
neighboring Town
um Newport has a great closed circuit
television setup
um every town meeting every school board
meeting planning board select board
zoning board they're all accounted for
our town has none of that
um
bandwidth at Town Hall is
Limited
but that's that's all able to be changed
and it should be changed in order to get
more of the public involved
I mean when when I thank you nope when I
started doing it
it was because of a school board related
issue
a year ago
and the majority of the town was
uninformed as to what was happening are
you speaking exactly to now the bill are
you
I'm speaking to the only reason I asked
is we are way behind and we're trying to
if you're speaking directly to the bill
I'm speaking to the service that the
bill would provide to others go ahead
as of last March
more towns uh sorry excuse me
residents of the town have become far
more involved in
all aspects of town governance all of it
it will boost interest
in positions in town it will provide
a means for folks to be heard who cannot
be in attendance at those meetings
in my opinion it's invaluable
okay thank you for your tests
timoni did you have a question
representative priest silk no okay
uh representative lasalles
you know very quickly uh is it your
opinion in Croydon the problem with
doing this is one of technology or is it
attitude on the part of town fathers
it would be a combination of the two
um
lack of bandwidth is a fixable problem
but the lack of ambition
to want to provide information to your
townsfolk can be a problem on all boards
and lack of transparency is an issue in
Croydon and
Statewide
thank you and I compliment you on taking
the initiative to do what you're doing
thank you very much sir
seeing no more questions thank you for
your testimony thank you very much you
ladies and gentlemen have a great day
next we have Zach May
all right good afternoon uh Mr chairman
and members of the committee my name is
Zach May and I'm here representing the
select Board of the Hamlet of Easton or
a town of 275 ish
with the town budget of uh 230 000. we
oppose the bill on two fronts one we
have no high-speed internet service at
the town that would sup in at the Town
Hall that would support video live
streaming
and two the technical and Personnel
costs to set up and maintain such a
systems and honest unnecessary expense
and disproportionately and it
disproportionate for a town of our size
uh especially given that the general
public is already allowed to record and
live stream
themselves I think it should be up to
each municipality to decide
choose whether to adopt
Town sponsored live streaming
thank you for your testimony any
questions reps Senate of yukela
thank you uh kind of going back to my
previous question about what if it was
just recording and not live streaming
since it is talked about
um and live streaming what if that was
just struck and it was just recording do
you think that that is
um enough of a benefit that you would be
in support of of recording your meetings
or are you already doing that yeah
uh
throughout certain periods uh throughout
certain um times in the past we have had
the public recording or
um so that is certainly up to them
um as as for the town you know we'd we'd
have to discuss it and you know if
whatever the town uh wants to do you
know obviously will respect that
representative Elward
good afternoon
does your town have a website yes we do
okay and are you able to upload video to
your website we are okay so it oh I'm
sorry follow-up Mr chairman would you
like a follow-up yes sir
follow-up
so it is possible for someone with an
iPhone or some type of
smartphone to upload video to the town
website where it can be archived for
future viewing
correct thank you
representative goth just quickly Mr
chairman thank you for allowing me to
ask a question thank you for your
testimony did I hear you write on the
size of your town
uh yes our population is uh just below
I imagine everybody in town knows
everything that's going on
yeah pretty much yes other you know even
even some of the seasonal residents do
thank you for your testimony sir good
thank you for your test testimony Mr May
uh last pink card I have is for Thomas
cormer Corman
foreign
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon I
am representative Tom Corman from
Grafton 15 which is Lebanon Ward 3. I am
here to support HB 295 which enhances
transparency in local government
as much as some of our constituents
might want to attend meetings of their
local elected officials they cannot
always manage to do so they might be ill
have mobility issues have no
Transportation be stuck at home caring
for children or their elderly relatives
have to work or just be playing too beat
after a day at work to go out HB 295
allows them to observe and participate
18 years ago I was hiring for an
administrative assistant position at
Dartmouth
one of the candidates I interviewed was
in Birmingham Alabama in order to
interview this person by video they had
to go to a studio in Birmingham and I
had to go to a studio on the Dartmouth
campus
we have come a long way since then now
access to live streaming is near
ubiquitous
I would suggest two friendly amendments
to the bill is written
first the bill specifically mentions
select boards and school boards as I
mentioned I live in Lebanon which is a
city
we have a city council rather than a
select board perhaps the bill could
apply to meetings of all elected
Municipal bodies which would Encompass
select boards City councils Boards of
aldermen and school boards
second and this is pretty relevant to
what we've been hearing because there
might be communities with insufficient
Broadband capability perhaps the bill
could contain language that it pertains
to municipalities with sufficient
Broadband to support live stream
meetings
that's all I had to say thank you
does anybody have any questions
not seeing any thank you for your
Thanksgiving
are there anybody anybody else wishing
to speak on this that was the last pink
card seeing none hearing on HP 295 is
now closed
on this car
okay we will now open the hearing on uh
House Bill four one six
relative to membership on certain local
land use Sports
what the record show I got a couple of
my sign lady
where's
the record
okay uh the representative uh Travis
Cochran introduced
not seeing representative Cochrane
available representative priest would
you take uh
just take the bill and introduce it for
us please
sit at the table please
seeing no questions thank you for your
introduction of the bill seeing no pink
cards I closed the hearing on uh
4 16.
I forgot to mention on a couple bills HB
295 the last one we had one two three
four in favor two against and on this
bill we had only one person sign up and
that was against
okay we're going to open up the
gonna open up the hearing on HB 77
relative to compensation for County
delegation meetings
we got to get here
love the player
okay uh we have nobody signed up to
speak we have nobody here to introduce
the bill uh representative Holland why
don't you come and introduce the bill
for us
no pressure uh I'm representative
Holland from Stratford 20 uh introducing
House Bill 77 local and act relative to
compensation of County delegate meetings
are there any questions
should anybody have any questions for
the representative seeing none we'll
close the hearing on HB 77.
hey we are within 15 minutes of being 20
minutes of being caught up
all right we're going to open up the
hearing now on HB 123 relative to the
governing bodies of the budget committee
and we represent uh
looks like representative Terry Roy will
be introducing the bill good afternoon
representative Roy
I hate to break your rule
and you're up okay good afternoon Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is representative Terry Roy I am a
representative from Rockingham District
31 that covers the towns of Deerfield
Auburn Candia and
Chester this bill would
limit the membership of the municipal
budget committee
with regard to the
um
select board member and the school board
member it would keep them as members
ex-officio they would not be able to
vote on the budget
having served on a municipal budget
committee for several years now what
I've noticed is that
the deck is stacked against the
taxpayers the way this is set up the
municipal budget committee
scheme was set up to give the taxpayers
a Fail-Safe
one more set of eyes to comb through the
budget and look for savings on their
behalf after the two bodies governing
bodies had finished their work
the way it is now
there's already two votes in favor of
those budgets before the budget
committees even get a chance to look at
them that would be akin to the governor
picking his two of his own executive
counselors
you know who they're going to vote for
in my experience I've never seen a
school board representative or town
representative vote against their own
budget or against the other's budget
this is unfair to the taxpayers on its
face
um I can't even I tried to play Devil's
Advocate I can't even think of a reason
why it would be that way
any changes that are proposed by the
municipal budget committee to cut taxes
are automatically faced with two votes
against them before they even start
so my proposal is to keep them there
because they're valuable members as far
as providing information to the board
they're a great resource but having them
the ability to vote on their own budget
and getting two bytes of the same Apple
they already voted for it and supported
it in their own board then coming again
getting another vote it's just so
fundamentally unfair and another
representative is going to speak to it
as well after I'm finished and I'm happy
to take any questions thank you
representative Roy are there any
questions representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question so
it's just a minor question and it
pertains to line seven the
um New text says governing body members
and then on line eight it says school
board ex-officio members is there a
particular reason why the adjective X
officio was omitted from
governing body members no there wasn't
that would be an Ella um the LSR was
just drafted that way I didn't catch
that thank you follow up
follow up thank you Mr chairman would
you um be willing to perhaps put in an
amendment to make to Absolutely I'll do
any leg work that you need to get it
finished absolutely
there any other questions seeing none
thank you represent whoop sorry
representative L Word
thank you
um and thank you for testifying today
on line seven
I'm sorry six it mentions an alternate
member does that apply to the new
language
um
would be ex-officio school board and
governing body and Alternate members no
it applies strictly to the two okay
thank you
okay now seeing no more questions thank
you representative Roy thank you
representative verbill
thank you Mr chairman thank you uh
honorable members of the the committee I
know it's been a long day for you and I
know I can get long-winded so I'll try
to be try to be short
um
I I was very pleased to hear that
representative Roy
um filed this to go back to the previous
question
um I I believe that is an error so it
would also it should also apply to the
alternate right so just for point of
clarification if we have a select board
member or a school board member that is
a member of the budget committee as
assigned by their
their their their boards and they are
not able to attend uh that's when they
they send the alternate and the
alternate would also not be not be
voting right so there's a tradition in
this this country it's a long tradition
and it's a good tradition and that's one
person one vote
and as representative Roy pointed out
these members have already had their
vote
they are a member of the uh the
originating body that drafts the budget
so they've they've had their chance to
say yes or no
to give them that chance again uh really
is a second bite at the Apple
the representatives that are coming from
select boards and from school boards
are there to represent the position of
their board the select board or the
school board
so we allow them to vote a second time
how does the school board member
know the position of the majority of the
school board
on a municipal budget line item
so I admit I haven't been to every town
I haven't been to every meeting but I've
never heard a school board discuss in
any detail a town budget
and likewise I have never heard a select
board discuss in any detail
a school board budget
but yet they're coming in
representing the boards they come from
so if I come from the select board I'm
voting on a school budget but I have no
way of knowing what it is the majority
of my board would support on those
questions
and that just seems
that just seems wrong
so for that reason I think it would be
an improvement to the system to make
them non-voting
members I I know in discussions with a
lot of people
one of the concerns would be will they
they won't show up
they won't participate
and I would say that's incorrect they
will certainly show up they will
certainly continue to participate one if
they if they don't I think the voters
would be very disappointed in that type
of behavior and they would probably get
voted out of office and even if even if
they choose not to participate
you know they're not they're not
required the budget committee can do
anything that it wants to do with the
majority with a majority vote so it's
obviously in their interest to come and
freely advise and so for that reason
um I I think this is a good bill I think
it does need a friendly amendment to
make sure that we're we're getting the
uh
the the replacement uh members as well
so thank you for your time and I'll take
any questions you may have
make sure your testimony represent
Elward
yeah
thank you it's good to see you this
afternoon
um are you familiar with
um incompatibility of offices under the
election
laws that says that a
no Selectmen
um School Board member except a
Cooperative School Board member shall at
the same time serve as a budget
Committee Member at large under RSA 32 I
am I'm sorry it's nice to see you this
afternoon as well yes thank you for the
question I I am aware of that and that
is that certainly flies in the face of
what we what we are currently doing and
that's why this bill is is needed so so
for clarity right
I live in Deerfield I'm rocking him too
right so I live in Deerfield I can't be
an elected member to the municipal
budget committee and the school board at
the same time
yet we allow the school board to appoint
a member to the municipal budget
committee as a voting member that
otherwise would be completely disallowed
by law and so that certainly is an
incongruity that supports passage of of
this legislation
thank you for the question
representative truella
thank you once again Mr chair and thanks
representative for coming to testify
before us today I'm not sure I just need
a clarification I'm not sure if I
misunderstood
um
the portion of the bill um line six
seven
that basically says each member if a
person is absent
each missing member shall be represented
by an alternate designated by the board
who then shall
when sitting have the same Authority as
the regular member
I understood you to say that they would
not so I I may have misunderstood you
yeah thank thank you so
um
I have to admit thinking on my feet
quickly is not my task give me a
question today and you'll get an awesome
answer tomorrow ask me a question today
you'll get a little bit of a sloppy uh
answer today because that's how my head
works so to be clear we have a school
board member that's appointed by the
school board a select board member
that's appointed by the select board
they also name alternates at the time
that they assign those roles so that if
the person that's designated to be that
that representative cross-board
representative is not available then the
alternate can sit in in the original
person's place
if the purpose of this legislation is to
keep the school board member to prevent
not keep to prevent the school board
member and the select board member from
voting on questions then it would stand
to reason that their alternates would
also be disallowed from voting on those
questions otherwise the they work around
on the law would simply be never send
the person that's appointed always send
the alternate and get the vote I do not
believe that the the alternates that are
discussed here are referring to elected
budget committee members elected from
elected at The Ballot Box Force just the
the budget committee that those
alternates are only referring back to
select and and school thank you
representative and I think you've um
you've blown your own estimation of
yourself because that was an excellent
answer and it's today it's now I really
appreciate it thank you I appreciate the
kind words thank you
um excuse me representative
oh
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
does the
does the budget committee is it is it
their responsibility to
present
uh the budget
and
uh
yeah to the to the other bodies and to
the public
thank you for the question it's an
excellent question
um just by way of of background so you
understand from where I come
um when I turned 18 I started going to
town meeting I grew up in Pembroke right
love love town meeting
moved around here and there and I've
lived in Deerfield a long time we're in
sb2 town so my familiarity is much
stronger with sb2 than it is with town
meeting only because decades have swept
past me
um over time
so the way it works in an sb2 town and I
believe as well as a traditional town
meeting but please correct me if I'm
wrong is that typically the select board
and the school board craft a proposed
budget so the school board would go to
the administration the administration
goes to to the staff to you know to the
teachers what not they craft this budget
and then they bring that to the budget
committee the same is true for the
select board so the select board talks
to department heads and and other people
under their charge they craft a budget
that budget is then given to the budget
committee when it's given to the budget
committee when it's handed over
it is now the municipal budget
committee's budget so the budget
committee can do whatever they see fit
with a majority vote with that budget
if it's a traditional town meeting the
next stop would be the town meeting and
there it would be debated by the general
public and whatever votes are taken
whatever decisions are made are Final in
an sb2 situation it would go to the
first session often referred to as the
deliberative session at the deliberative
session again the general public has the
the right to show up ask questions
debate make motions and make changes
with limitations
so that's the the deliberative session
gets the budget committee's budget and
then whatever they pass out of
deliberative that's what would appear um
on the the warrant to be voted um at the
at the general election
okay does that answer your question sir
yep thank you
Mr chairman representative majority
thank you Mr chairman just to uh uh
um representative Missouri's up
somebody's on the board has a name like
me I'm sorry Mr
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question for clarity it says
on any matter if there is an amendment
in the budget committee meeting
is would you would this say that the
select board representative then is also
not allowed to vote on that Amendment
just the amendment not the
recommendation of the budget in total
but on just the amendment also would it
include any amendment is my question all
right thank you for the question so the
the the purpose and the intent of the
legislation is to disallow select board
members and school board members to vote
on any and all questions coming before
that committee so they're there in an
advisory role so if somebody makes a
motion to add a hundred thousand dollars
to Highway
um the the select board member would not
be voting on that Amendment it's it's
just there just there for advisory
purposes
thank you and you I don't know how old
you are but you look great for your age
representative Guthrie
thank you thank you Mr chairman I
apologize my hearing isn't working too
good tonight
uh sir thank you for coming and
testifying and taking my question am I
correct in saying that on the Senate
Bill too that uh as in my town the
budget committee is advisory and has no
no power at all it's just an advisory
committee thank you for the question and
is that and is that the case in all
Senate Bill towns yeah thank you for the
question and and I apologize
um to to Really
um flesh out how local government works
there's there's a lot of details
representative verbal I think we're kind
of there are two types they're advisory
um budget committees and they're
authoritative budget committees
um this really
um is is for both but but critically
important for authoritative budget
committees because they are actually
um
a middle step between the governing body
and the deliberative session I agree
thank you very much sir thank you Mr
chairman
any other questions
see none thank you representative
verville thank you I appreciate the time
yes sir
uh next I have uh Stephen got it go to
good afternoon Mr chairman
members of this committee my name is
Stephen gadu I'm from Salem New
Hampshire I currently serve as chairman
of the budget committee Municipal budget
Committee in Salem New Hampshire uh I
have been on the budget committee for
seven budgets uh and I'm currently the
chair for the second year in a row man
rep for a point of personal preference
sure can we figure out how the sun is
shining in the in the witness's eyes so
we can help him out yeah thank you
there he just solved it all right thanks
I was gonna close the blinds thank you
Mr thank you for pointing that out
um
I'm here in support of this bill
and um the main reason that we should be
supporting this bill is that there is a
built-in obstruction to the intent that
this bill was originally written that
obstruction is the addition of members
from the border Selectmen and the budget
and the
and the school boards who get to vote
the um
in sb2 the budget committees are the
governing body that actually sets the
budget the budgets that we receive are
proposed and then we set the budget that
goes to the town deliberative session
which in turn ends up on the ballot with
whatever amendments come in
my experience over the past seven
budgets is that we have never had a
school board member or a select board
member vote against or vote for any
changes to the budgets it's it's not
only an Unwritten rule rule but candidly
the representative from the uh
School Board in the most recent budget
even said to me well
I expect the select board member to vote
for my budget I mean it's it's not it's
just an automatic that we have
two people against making any changes we
have a seven member board that's elected
as a budget committee to make the
decision for the town
um the budget the intention of having a
budget committee is specifically so that
the the the boards that are proposing
their budget are not the ones that are
approving the budget it's none of the
towns are required to have a budget
committee even under sb2 we could just
let it run as uh the select board and
the school uh board could vote on the
budget and that would be it but the
budget committees are specifically
installed to govern the uh to to act as
a governor to prevent unnecessary
spending and to keep taxes in check
and they need to be independent they're
not independent when we have two votes
against we have seven members of our
budget committee I need to have five
votes to make any cuts for the first
five years that I presided over the
budgets
I had members on the committee that was
simply rubber stamps they just whatever
the town and the school proposed they
just said yes we couldn't cut 10 cents
out of the budget because I didn't have
a majority now I've worked hard at
recruiting members to join the budget
committee that are willing to be
reasonable and
and potentially make changes to the
proposed budgets from these uh other
boards and I need five members of a
seven member board
in order to make any change
the seven members were elected to be on
the budget committee that's their job
that's what the voters have intended and
I believe that's the intention of the
original Law and I I doubt that when the
original law was a place that they had
considered the possibility that the two
members from the the school board and
the select board would always vote
against every budget change I'm sure
that the intention was to have them
there to advise the budget committee
members who are elected to
manage the budget
so I think this really is a correction
to the intention and the spirit of the
law that was originally written and I
can tell you from my experience that we
are being obstructed and if I had not
been able to uh get five members of our
seven-member board elected we would not
be able to control our budget in Salem
New Hampshire and it's it's an important
function of every government to have an
independent uh group to be able to look
at what is being spent and to try to
keep our taxes affordable and especially
affordable for the the folks who don't
have a lot of money I I I'm there
fighting for the people who are on you
know having difficulty paying their
bills and paying the heating bills and
that's my concern I never hear from
constituents that say to me boy you
should raise the taxes so that we could
do more I mean there's an unlimited
amount of Mr Dakota
um I know you you weren't probably in
the room prior but we were trying to
limit testimony to a reasonable amount
of time we didn't start a a clock on you
but if you could get very close to
wrapping it up and speak exactly kind of
to this I understand
your passion but if you could thank you
thank you uh well I've pretty much said
what I need to uh Express I'd be happy
to answer any questions that you would
have from my experience on the budget
committee thank you for your testimony
are there any questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you very much
uh next like to call Robert Clegg please
I I uh who's that Ted trust yes yeah
that's fine sure uh we'll call it Ted
Trust
uh thank you Mr chair and honorable
committee members my name is Ted trost
I'm from the town of Hudson I've served
on the Hudson budget committee now for
eight budget cycles and am the current
chair of the Hudson budget committee I
support hb123
some of you may recall that last spring
the Hudson budget committee took actions
to strip the budget the school board and
the board of Selectmen from voting on
the budget committee this resulted in
the school board in select board suing
the budget committee which we ultimately
lost
um
I'm asking for this bill to pass because
the school board and board of Selectmen
in in communities spend many weeks
crafting their budgets before forwarding
a final budget to the respective budget
committee to allow those Liaisons to
have votes on the budget committees
after they have already completed their
work and allowed them to now vote again
on changes to their budgets allows for
them to subvert the budget committee's
efforts to present a budget that the
voters find agreeable and represents a
prudent appropriation of public funds
the primary effect of leaving the boards
with voting ability that is to not pass
this bill on a budget committee is to
impede the ability of a budget committee
to formulate its own budget to present
to the voters
when a motion is made in a budget
committee to reduce budget amounts
the Liaisons from those boards
invariably vote about vote against it
every motion to reduce a school budget
or a town budget in a budget committee
and inevitably starts with one and
sometimes two vote disadvantage
I ask that you vote ought to pass and
return the full budget process to the
budget committees
any questions representative power thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question
um
when a municipality has a statutory
budget committee that's an official
budget committee as opposed to a finance
committee which is advisory only
is it specified in statute that the
budget
belongs to the budget committee and
therefore the budget committee is
responsible for
crafting
that budget it's their budget it
originates with the budget committee and
that a governing body select board or
School Board they provide input to that
so I'm a little confused as to why I've
heard testimony
stating that these governing bodies
they have budgets and there's a conflict
between two budgets could you speak to
them yes thank you for the question that
was confusing to me as well when I
started on the budget committee so it's
it's my understanding that
in the case of budgets
um the school board and the select board
both prepare their budgets and forwarded
them to the budget committees whether
they are required to or not I'm not
really clear on that however that is the
way that it works in Hudson we are an
sb2 community in case that's relevant
um the budget committee at that point
does have the option we could throw
those budgets in the garbage and start
from scratch we absolutely could do that
however
speaking for myself not the budget
committee
um
there is value in seeing where they
Place their priorities where they see
changes that need to be made it does
spur discussion with those board members
who appear before or who appear with us
in the budget committee
um so I see there is value for that but
that is that is the way that it works
um in Hudson is that the school board
and the board of Select do prepare a
budget and forward it to the budget
committee
further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you uh now Robert
foreign
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Robert Clegg I also
serve on the Hudson's budget committee
and I apologize because I I had copies
of the court case which may answer a
whole lot of questions I'll bring them
tomorrow I don't know where I left them
there's some place over on the other
body
um when we when we were sued by the
Hudson school board and in the board of
Selectmen we were sued because we
decided in the law it says Liaisons
and in the law you have ex-official
members
our members that come in from the school
board and from the select board are
Liaisons
so we said we read the law that's and
you can't vote
so they sued us
the superior court judge
decided that Liaisons Annex official
members are the same
and she decided that we were wrong in
that they had every right to vote
the
lawyer for the
the town
basically said that
no member of the school board or the
board of Selectmen was required to vote
as the school board or the board of
Selectmen had voted already
just the other night we had the chair of
the school board
as the representative sitting on our
committee tell us he voted against
the expenditure of 27 million dollars as
the chair of the school board
but since he was there as the
liaisonic's official member of the
school board he would have to change his
vote in the committee
and vote in favor of the expenditure
and that's what we found everything they
said to the court
is untrue they come they have one vote
One Voice
and and and the courts don't believe it
and the courts basically said fix the
law
I as I said I will get you the court
case
um I'll drop have it dropped off at your
office I know you're in session tomorrow
um but it's very important that you see
that the courts
we everything most people here said
already is what we did
we could have taken it and we could have
gone to the Supreme Court but the budget
committee didn't feel right about
spending any money we represented
ourselves in the Superior Court
and said there's no reason for us to
spend the money they spent
tens of thousands of dollars to make
sure that they had a vote on the budget
committee
so my chairman had to leave because we
actually had to suspend our vote the
other night
until today because the
schools refused to give us information
and figured well if we don't give you
the information and you can't vote on it
so we have a very contentious system in
Hudson always has been we are an sb2
town
but this law is absolutely positively
needed I would like to offer that we
need to talk about Liaisons as well it's
in the same statute just not this
section a liaison and an ex-officio
member shouldn't vote they should be
there as advisory they should be able to
explain to us why they did something
that maybe we don't understand but
beyond that
um this isn't my first time on the board
so most of us that sit there sit there
because we're trying to keep taxes done
we're a working family time
thank you very much
you were done sorry representative
Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman welcome back
uh am I
how many members are on the budget
committee if the school and the in the
town is excluded as liaison uh whatever
ex-officio so when these step away
how many members how many voting members
are on the board is it five or seven do
you have a seven member budget board
with two alaisons or do you have
seven just seven members uh what What's
the what's the breakup of the committee
when you make these two ex-officios not
being able to vote we have seven actual
elected people to the budget committee
and then we have two Liaisons making the
total number of votes that we have to
count nine
and as the chair said previously from
the Dodson chair
um we start out with two no votes on any
cut we ever do and if somebody's not
there we actually have
um another member who is a
is in Conflict but
she's she's a full-time employee of the
school and the law says you can't be on
the budget committee
they've played so much with the budget
committee laws that this is the first
step towards actually creating something
that allows the people's voice to be
heard I'm if I may
if my name is to change is to clarify I
don't think I was clear how many members
let's assume that the two are off we
pass this legislation so now you've got
five members and two liaison or do you
have seven members
we have seven we have seven members okay
so the two liaison it's still a
seven-member board that's going to come
in with a recommendation so that makes
it even more reason to do this take this
action there's still seven members
looking at the budget yes thank you Mr
chairman and thank you
are there any other questions
seeing none
um before I close the hearing gentlemen
you are going to work on clarifying some
of the language
excellent very good uh take your time on
it make sure
we get it good Amendment on that okay
thank you
any other question any other speakers I
see none
so we'll close the hearing on HB 123 we
had uh
or in favor and to sign in against
so
we will see everybody tomorrow morning
at 10 30 again here uh Republicans we
have a 9 30 caucus in this room and
Republicans before you leave today could
you give us about five more minutes and
we'd ask that the Democrats give us the
room here fairly quickly and with that
we'll see everybody tomorrow thank you
I'm sorry it was my understanding that
we're running about an hour
foreign